what up guys welcome to the just early
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
Miami all right before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos make sure you like the video on
your way in that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams so let's get this stream
to 2,000 likes welcome to the show
ladies to start we're going to go around
everyone say and sir we're going to say
um name age relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself starting here
and then go around my name is Dena Cruz
I am
38 and I am single and I am a stand-up
comedian so that's my fun fact cool hi
everybody my name's Nina I'm
25 I'm
Singlish
Singlish um a fun fact about me is I
love running track
what is Singlish Singlish is I I
actually we tried to Define these last
show yes you tell me and no no I was
really confused is Singlish like your
your dating going on dates with a guy
with one well yeah yeah yeah with a guy
I imagine it's like one yeah okay but
you guys just haven't defined it yet
yeah you can't Define it off like the
first or second date you know oh okay oh
so you like him so much you've gone on
like two dates and you're like uh oh my
god oh wow you're in
lovey to Chas wow wow she's like she's
like I don't need anyone else how long
have you seen him for um it's been a
long time we've been talking for like
maybe a little over a year oh a year oh
here I thought this was like two dates
and no but we've only been on a couple
of dates that's a red flag no it's not a
red flag okay how do you know I've been
busy how do I know what the guy how do
you know
him dang I stopped and it's just getting
into me um social media okay so you guys
met online and you've known him for like
a year yes but and you're in love oh
yeah I can see it in your
eyes but we don't we didn't even defined
it yet no okay Singlish okay I'm sort of
I I was expecting two dates this is very
interesting okay all right what about
you hi I'm Laura I'm 30 and I'm single
and I like to sing that's
interesting what what do you do for a
living um I Barton and I am getting into
it okay I'm Steve I'm 35 I'm single and
I'm the co-host of the unfiltered
podcast I'm also the producer as
well hi I'm Amy I'm 28 years old I'm
single and fun fact I'm Australian FAS
where you from Australia I've been in
the states for like 6 years so my
accent's a little bit weird like people
like you're doing a fake American accent
or a fake Australian accent it's like
it's just weirdly muddled at this point
yeah awesome okay I'm Christy I'm
29 fun facted about me I am a mom of two
I guess what do you do um I am a dog
trainer and a model um a dog trainer
what's the coolest trick that you've
ever taught a dog oh cool damn I usually
just get hired to do the basics I guess
the coolest thing I do is psychiatric
service dog training so like medication
retrievals and like tactile simulations
like that because they're going to tell
me
Ghosts no I mean the most thing you know
they're like more like basic courses not
so much like show dogs got it so you get
me but yeah but if I if I sent my dog to
you she'd come back and like Tip Top she
would come back a soldier okay what
about
you hi my name is Alandra I'm a medical
assist ician and I'm a bartender on the
weekends and a fun fact about me I love
working out what is a medical
aesthetician um so the one that does
facials chemical peels microabrasion is
that like botox and that sort of stuff
no I want to do that though but you got
to be in the nursing program to do that
I was curious like what's the most
common treatments that you get uh
chemical peels for pigmentation for sun
damage we live out here we're always out
I need you to hit I'm you my first
question I want to know so if I move
here do I have to get like hop plastic
surgery I heard everyone's like yes you
do so who who your had PL who yours had
work done okay what what have you guys
had done my boobs titties okay was it
worth it to you was it worth it to you
guys uh yeah it was worth it to me I
don't regret it I mean I like it you
know put on a bikini I'm like
wow where did these come
from was it painful it was yeah it was
and I got my boobs done through my
armpit like under the muscle so like my
incision is down there it's not even on
my boobs so it took me a little extra
you guys have to get them like out later
how does that every 10 years you got to
get them redone so it's like 15 years 15
years yeah it's like 15 years for the
gummy bears wow so how common is that is
that normal here that's super especially
in the lower region this is like BBL
Central man yeah that's true nobody's
else is that big they can pretty much
they can pretty much
fly you ladies can pretty much fly to
Columbia or Brazil or wherever Dr and
get a BBL basally why would you do that
if you could just get it here get it
here Dr Miami some
cans so I wouldn't go anywhere else I
did my boops here too are women honest
about getting work done do you I am I
want to say it's like a 50/50 yeah I
agree I just want to know if if I if I
meet six Miami girls two have work done
or two
lying I think we have some at the table
one more I think there might be someone
else that okay does anyone think anyone
at the table's
lying let me let me look let me no it's
just me and her looks natural she thinks
you thinks someone's lying no I mean
everyone looks pretty natural here yeah
yeah I I don't know I'm just let me see
your
titties
I actually I wouldn't have even
noticed I told the doctor though I was
like make sure it's sufficient enough or
it looks pretty natural because you know
and the gummy drops because if you do
your boobs too big then you start
looking like an an out you know like
you're about to play football so I don't
want to do I knew a girl her boobs were
pointed up oh my God I've seen that
seen I've seen the nipples going like
the worst oh the googly eyes
oh sometimes some
you guys look fine you guys look you
guys look good yeah AR but you got to
really look at them to like you
know so how does dating work in Miami um
what typically comes
K just go home not kidding in a given
all right so we have single single most
people are single here so in a given
month um I forgot to tell you I I
skipped my relationship status I'm
taking okay you also skipped your
relationship status too what's oh I am
seeing someone so okay okay let's what
what does that mean that's how long have
you known the guy so let's see it's been
like what uh a month and a half okay a
month and a half okay and you guys are
going on dates yeah we're going on dates
checking up on each other just like
intro you know okay and steps but I'm
not going to go crazy okay and do you
want to be do do you want to be with him
oh yeah yeah and how long would you see
him without being exclusive till you cut
it o yeah how long girl that was good
okay on well every girl's got a limit
she hers is a year I
guess okay that's too long for me it's
two months and two months he needs to
get clarify she's got two weeks yeah
that's it so so how are you how are you
going to chop chop okay so how are you
going to bring up this conversation oh
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to set the tone obviously after we
eat and everything once we get to bed
once he's super comfy and ready to go to
sleep hey babe so that's exactly how I'm
doing and I'm going just tell him so
what are we okay have you have you
already had sex with
him I have well I mean they're in bed so
it's like I thought we like sleeping
over every other night I mean so okay my
little companion okay so um and then are
you seeing anyone else too or is it just
him not like that I I'm still texting
back people but not necessarily like
that it's like I'm trying to cut them
off okay are you would you go on a date
like let's say this young fine young man
right here said let's go on a date after
the show are you going no because for
the most part I usually work and if I'm
not working I rather go be with him so
okay okay so but any Brad Pit comes up
to you I'm going on a date oh well PE
you just spiced it up you said Brad P
well I mean I just want to know how
loyal you are I'm trying to figure out
how loyal Miami chicks are a guy that
they're talking about listen I just yeah
but she's thinking about this is what I
just got here so it's like I got here so
it's like I mean I'm not saying you
should be I'm just asking yeah H so so
you're you're kind of open she said Brad
Pit I mean you're saying Brad Pit but
it's like I would just want a picture
maybe a small conversation and then buy
okay here's a good question for though
if a guy came along that was willing to
pay for your date or take you out like
he was a rich guy and he just said look
come out I I'll pay you to come out with
me are you going to entertain him no
rather just just go with my man's I mean
he lives in a nice area that's common in
Miami where guys just true that's true
that is true has anyone here been paid
to hang out with a guy raise your hand
okay so wow wow see this is the all
right so what what what happened what do
you pay you for he to go on a date with
him okay was it like an ask did you have
to put out or was it just dat no no no
no not at all um it was actually a
somebody that my friend introduced me to
and then he wrote to me on Instagram and
he asked me out and I was like I'm busy
work and he was like oh I'll pay you if
you miss work I'll pay you the money
that you made at work so I was like okay
he give me a little extra so
yeah that's just nice though that's
being nice you said that to you too need
that's like common
C
I'm my second podcast I'm still getting
that's why I have this but umid
confidence yeah they like they asked us
like a few of us to go to 11 and they
just gave us someone 11's a strip club
so oh how much how much money money did
you get I got 500 500 two like 200 yeah
they just gave it to us you didn't have
to sleep with them no like a hand job no
nothing no I'm not going to lie though
after that day he was throwing hints
like you owe me a little something and
then I had to block him well he wanted
to it up and be like got you girl do you
have their number just for that's
hilarious no he's on my blog list he's
been there for a while but I got you
girl throw 500 bucks you just got to sit
there I I that block
just kidding the guy I went with was
just on a power trip like he was just
like oh here I got
money never show it's okay how is dating
different in Australia to here oh that's
a good one um I I don't know I have been
someone who's a very long-term
relationship person so I've been in like
four serious relationships pretty much
my whole life and I've never someone who
like dated a bunch of people in between
it was more so I've never been on the
apps I've never been about any of that
life it's more so just organic and
people who I meet through like my
day-to-day life so how does that so how
does the process work to get this the
boyfriend wait so first actually first
question was this in
Miami which part the long-term
relationship uh one of them yeah I
you're in a relationship yeah no but
when like once you got here did you find
I was already in a relationship so we
were already dating for like nearly 2
years and then we moved here and we were
dating for like another year and a half
sorry I've been single for about the
last six months okay so impossible to
find
boyfriend really like I don't know how
to date here at all at all okay so
before you got here what was the process
you would beat a friend and then You' go
on a date how would it work yeah pretty
much it's just people either organically
through like a work environment a mutual
friend environment like back in
Australia like a church environment
whatever it may be okay and then like
what would you how long would you talk
to them before boyfriend um or would it
just go straight would they say be my
girlfriend yeah usually a couple of
months I would say okay yeah so 3 months
six months two month no yeah two to
three months something like that I would
say and now at three months you would
leave
assuming yeah I mean again I was never
really like going on dates I I don't
think I've ever really been corded you
know how women talk about being corded
whin and D it was never like that it was
always just something that was more
organic that like you would hang out
yeah exactly and then evolved into
something more over time yeah I've
honestly never been romanticized like
the way girls talk about like guys who
drop cash take them out on these F like
I've never had that my whole life but
would you like to have it you should
have it I mean maybe but it seems like
it comes with more problems than it's
worth sometimes based on what I've heard
on a lot of these different I don't know
maybe what what about do you guys agree
with that is it more normal to be
courted or to they need a and hang out I
think it is more normal to I mean in my
head i' rather get they got to show more
initiation she's saying wind and D wind
and D we can hang out I think it comes
with age I feel like when you don't have
the money when you're young maybe not so
much but when you get older and you know
the guy can afford to take you on dates
it's a little it's a little different so
in Miami I get nice dates
definitely what did you say yeah I think
it's normal to be taken out on nice
dates yeah normal nice I think it's a
5050 thing I think it depends on what
you're on person like to be honest with
you like i' I've had like both of the
experiences like I was married for 10
years I've been divorced for five so
like it's different like I've seen both
sides of the fence like and not to say
when I was in a relationship like he
whined and died me then you know but I'm
just saying like that quoting face up
until becoming the girlfriend that was a
little bit different for me compared to
what it seems like his people's
experience okay what about you so how
does it work for you talking phas and
how how long are you you stay in um like
about two months too but I would say it
depends on the person like if you know I
I just want him to give me the best
experience he'll give any other woman so
if he's the type of guy that's more like
emotionally in tune I just want all of
that I want whatever the most he has to
offer you
know that's why I'm saying it just
depends on the girl though yeah you know
okay it depends that's I'm try that's
what I'm trying to find out for each 20
years I can get an average I definitely
want to be wh and D yeah now at this age
yeah cuz I know every guy he's got a
wine and dine for two to three months
and then you're going into a
relationship he doesn't have like we
don't have to go on super expensive UMES
all the time together yeah like he can
take me to just like a creative little
hole-in-the-wall spot that has really
good food and then on a
romantic I don't know like watch yeah
like see a nice little view somewhere
yeah okay what about you um I want to
date like I want to be taken out on
dates at least for a good two to three
months yeah not back to back to back to
back and not crazy things every time but
I want to be taking out on dates so it
seems like the talking phase here is two
to three
months no no no you said a year no you
guys assumed I said I knew him for a
year I said I knew the person for a year
how long was it romantic it's been about
a month or two so you've known him for a
year and two months it's been romantic
so he's got about four weeks to pop the
question who initiated did he initiate
or did you like the interest after the
friendship um yeah it was both cuz it
was kind of after a friendship so it was
kind of just like wow this works so good
who was dropping the hint though like
who made that move definitely both it
was what like it was him and I was
agreeing and then it would be me and he
was agreeing like that okay flirtatious
back and
forth what about about you how does it
work to you you're divorced you were
married before I was what's the process
now I'm still trying to figure it out
and I'm five years in that's how
complicated is Pearl so I don't even
think we have we some pns in the last
five years um patterns in the last five
years I think I would definitely agree
that the talking phase is like three
months I think in three months a guy
shows you if he's consistent a guy will
show you whether or not his behaviors
have changed um um cuz that usually
happens too like you can spot like the
patterns early on like within a month or
two you're even it's pretty easy
honestly to judge a guy's intentions
like within like maybe the first week
yeah you can tell like what I think it's
it's to know when's the last time some
of the ladies been on a date cuz some of
them probably haven't been on a date how
long have you when's the last time you
were on a date last time I was on a date
like was no it was I mean I just
recently stopped talking to someone so
it was
maybe a month ago not even okay what
about you who else is single and but
before that it was a long time it was
like a year I'm picky I'm GNA be honest
with you picky some of you take forever
to find yourself and you [__] pretty
much don't go on dates for years and you
think you go back into the dating Market
dat a guy but you don't really have any
experience dating does that make sense
like if you don't go on dates that does
make sense not going to know how to date
so when who else said two to three
months and who else hasn't been on a
date in a while oh no I've been on date
Sunday you haven't been Sunday frunch I
just I haven't really been I haven't
actively been on a date since me and my
ex BR cup cuz it was like a nearly four
year relationship probably the most
serious relationship I've ever been in
thought it would be like the father to
my my children everything like that so I
didn't want to jump into dating until I
had like I I didn't want to rebound or
anything like that you know how long
should it take though before you I mean
are you on Tinder are you on any apps
I've never been on any of the apps no um
I think that I'm like getting close to
being ready um and it'll getting close
to being ready what does that mean she's
almost done healing I've had office I've
had offers and I'm just about ready to
maybe take some of them up possibly Pi
have offers okay are these guys are
these guys that you actually are are
these guys that you're attracted to
though cuz you ladies get offers but
there there a bunch of guys don't like
yeah yeah I would say so mhm but for me
I'm I'm like physically yes like check
marks like other kind of Standards or
prerequisites but you never really know
until you're like talking to someone and
if that chemistry is there you know so
so far as that's concerned I can't say
for sure but in other more superficial
areas I would say like yeah the box is a
check okay how many of you ladies are
against dating apps dating tnder Bumble
I don't like apps why I don't I just I
don't know I feel like it's c a little B
it's impersonal it's creating an image
and like per se it might not even be you
so it's like that's true too I rather
meet you on on site like on the spot
yeah I'm very much a believer in like
the I like that in person instantly look
at you it's like okay when's the last
time so who's been on a date in the past
week raise your hand I was okay who's
been on a date in the past two weeks
past
month okay past 3
months 6 months R red flag red flag I
haven't been on an official date since
me and my expert Cup oh who hurts you
what do you
just so sad what's like an official date
what do you like a guy like ask you out
and you're kind of not necessarily
quoted and whin and DED but it's it's an
official thing it's like we made this
plan I want to spend this time with you
and we show up and do that a picnic I
think
I mean I've been in situations where
we're hanging out with people and then I
end up hanging out with somebody but
it's not like it's pre-planned or
anything you
know okay I think you just need a Vibe
really well with the person on a date I
don't know I mean I guess I know guys
hate that word like do I like I'm 5 one
yeah I now I now I want to hear dating
in Miami from the guy's point of view
all right so typically how long does a
chick um make you wait for sex
here oh look at their
face it depends what type of man you are
okay that's true I'm asking I'm asking
your experience first like I mean like
what do you guys justify as hooking up
like like full out like yeah I mean I
guess like first second date first
second date wow okay so immediately all
right what about
you it depends on the girl realistically
if if uh it's just some you Miami girl
then yeah probably in the first 10
minutes but if it's uh yeah if it's I
guess a respectable girl or it depends
depends what she thinks I mean there's
there's plenty of respectable girls that
could get him the first night too yeah
how does that work like [__] the date
let's get out of here he's talking about
the on campus girls for
sure I mean they're if they're from um
Miami like yeah they walk through the
door and they just they know it's about
to they take their shirt off I'm trying
to I'm learning they they know they're
going to get rail yeah what about
you
would you say the averages uh I mean for
me personally I would say at least two
to three dates and then I'm hooking up
and I've had some One Nights a lot of
One Nights dance yeah I'm a DJ so girls
like want to be in the DJ booth they
want to look that's your body count yeah
for real that's lost gone5 hard okay
that's not that well for a guy that's
not
that girl said wow wh yes a wh girl we
know guys can't be [__] we're more
makers the only way a guy can be a [__]
if he's banging twos that's that's the
only way
be I think guys can be whes like I I
think you can if if you bang enough
girls and it doesn't mean anything I
think you can be a [__] I think they're
horror makers exactly exactly cuz
they're making too much love think about
so 75 I was like that's 75 wives
someday that
maybe like 25 yeah not one of them are
going to be
wi yeah fair enough that's true won't
get married so they want all be wives so
okay so question what about like how
long do you guys are in a talking phase
with a chick until you ask her to be
your girlfriend ahead oh I've never even
had like a formal girlfriend I mean I'm
only 22 oh okay oh you're not so okay
but you meet a chick tomorrow you're
like she's
awesome how long are you waiting um I
don't know probably like a month or two
I feel like that's a good amount of time
or two I don't know if you go on a few
dates a week or something like that you
should know at that point that's nice
okay I mean I don't really set yeah I
don't really set a time liit on it it's
just whenever she's ready she'll kind of
Hint it it could take 3 weeks it could
take two months three months usually
after before three months if she
actually likes you she'll give you the
little little hint but uh yeah you don't
set exact times on I'm I'm not setting a
time and like WR in my notebook I'm
going to ask her to be my girlfriend on
this date it's kind of just whenever she
brings it up a few days after that then
you so you let her take the initiation
no no I take the initiation she'll bring
it up we'll have a little talk the hit
you'll take the clues like yeah and then
in a few days I'm like by the way
congrats you're my
girlfriend congratulations you know so
you tell them they're your girlfriend
you don't even ask you're just like they
already been like yeah okay got it um
for me it's at least six to eight months
I definitely would not jump into
anything I have to vet hold on don't say
well a second um I want to make sure uh
we have our first argument first to see
how [__] she is so I think you don't
know anybody because in the first month
or two maybe she's putting on like a
mask you don't really know how she she F
Fair um women's True Colors come out
when they get angry at you so I give it
at least a couple arguments that usually
takes six you got to see if she throws a
slipper or throws a knife
exactly why is it Tak gets angry why is
it taking 6 months for her to get mad at
you though yeah she's going to get mad
before that it sounds like you're the
one who has the mask on no not not at
all I think that a lot of women I dated
a girl who literally when she would get
mad she'd go and [__] some other dude
yeah that's what I'm saying you have to
see if she fights Fair like so she was
silent she was like her get back was
crazy okay her get back was crazy my
next question about Miami dating how
common is cheating here how real common
let's if you're dating out in Miami are
you going to get cheated on let's go uh
I would say it's like a 75 25% chance it
depends on the guy too the type of guy
that you're dating okay you know who are
the better guys to not get cheated on by
uh the normal ones the ones that have
regular jobs the ones that can't get
other PS um no not necessarily are the
guys to stay away from uh the really
pretty ones okay they can get other no
no no no that's not true that's not
true um no but no not date ugly men not
date ugly men I just feel
like again you have to understand Miami
is a very superficial City okay
superficial in the sense that you can
meet a pretty man who is not that pretty
in his day-to-day life you know what I
mean maybe he has like I don't know
$50,000 worth of child support that he
owes somebody something like that does
that happen to you no I'm just saying
like I do you know someone that's
happened to you yeah actually I know a
lot of girls that crazy stuff like that
has happened too you know what I mean so
you have to understand that there yes
there is this Miami that's full of
influencers and then there's a whole
other Miami with regular people who are
kind of [__] up like some of them you
know what I mean what did your exes do
my ex husband yeah uh he's a
superintendent for a demolition company
okay is that a good job uh yeah they
make very good money actually I meant
like in terms of like I mean not get
cheated on yeah oh to not get cheated on
um I think if a man wants to cheat he's
going to cheat no matter what he does
for a living to be honest with you okay
like it's the man you know what I mean
so what about women what what are the
what women in Miami cheat the
most what women in Miami cheat the
most depends how they feel in the
relationship he doesn't want to set
anybody up without a real man is a
boyfriend people with the most options
all girls have options um I would
say true the ones that actually have a
personality because there's a lot of
pretty girls in Miami like that's the
norm here but the ones that have an
actual personality definitely have an
added like up on top so they'll cheat
more the ones with they have more
options
taking that back okay um so am do you
just get cheated on in Miami what's your
opinion I feel like yeah
85% and I also feel like it's so much
more common to get cheated on like not
physically just flirtatious flirting on
the gram things like that that's too
common do you think like liking another
girl's picture is that cheat raise a
hands is that cheating no I don't think
that's cheating messaging another girl
cheating raise your hand what's the
message yeah what's the message about
hey no
yeah yeah what are you say hey to her
for say okay but you say 85% of men here
cheat yeah okay no damn I I I'm I I'm
not I was just talking about this today
I think all men cheat I came from all
men all men cheat doesn't matter they
going to cheat on you sometime if you
planning to marry them your whole life
they going to cheat yeah that's why I
got a little little thing I like to do
what percent of men have had more than
one sexual partner in the last
year 10% 10% of men 10% of men yeah 10%
they surveyed 5,000 men in 2022 that's
what they said can any of you ladies
relate 5,000 men doesn't to having the
question relate to what to only having
one sexual partner in the last year I
can to us cheating to having over one
partner last one partner in the last
year I can no she said one that was the
statistic one no more than one more than
one yeah no so so 10% of men have had
more than one sexual partner in the past
year only three 33% of men have had more
than one sexual partner in their
lifetime okay like sorry in a year in
their lifetime sorry okay does that make
sense so but more than one that could be
many though so that could be 20 it could
be 30 it could be 50 I I know but I'm
saying only 10% of men have slept with
more than one chick in the last year oh
so what you're saying is 90% of men
haven't slept with any chicks in the
year
more than one one
yeah two or L I'm not getting
Sor that statistic Works probably more
outside of Miami than here okay cuz like
he just said girls are giving it up in
10 minutes you know what I'm saying the
super like hypers sexualized so what do
you think can you find a boyfriend that
does not cheat here no for for my
experience um I think men are just
really openly cheaters here like they'll
they're not cheating though they just
tell you they have several women and if
you're I mean they don't even ask if
you're okay with their dig so who did
someone tell you
that yeah a few a few honest honest I
haven't really dated since I've okay so
cuz you're thinking of something I'm
guessing what what did that person
do I think they more or so like their
game or whatever is just like just like
saying it like carelessly so you can
just kind of like not really digest it
but just okay he has girl and then just
okay what what happened I need to hear
this
story um we were on a date we were like
getting romantic it was getting cute
whatever we were um I think we went to
the beach or something after just
hanging out and
then um his girlfriend called bro his
girlfriend called and um I was like oh
you have a girl he's like oh yeah
casually after I've been with him for
like two hours what what did he do for a
living um not nothing legal nothing she
could say on air we already know what
that means well okay okay he was a
businessman
but
cover
mear there's a lot of drug dealers here
as L scammers here yeah scammers and Dr
deers to and women love to be Dr dealers
will cheat on you and scammers in
Miami I'm just taking notes all right
literally all right so what's dating
been like for you here you wanted to
date this week how'd it go
bro bro it's kind of a detriment like
these girls like I don't know why they
ask my body count on like the second
date like that's not a usual thing your
still yeah would they
ask that's happen to multiple times
where a girl ask for my body count I
heard in Florida some people like keep
track of their bodies like in a notebook
like yo open up your notes everyone open
up the notes right now let's see it I
didn't five today I don't got a notebook
I got him up here told me that maybe
there's only some guys okay so she asked
you your body count yeah she asked my
body count on the you said second date
second date and uh hers was over 10 and
she's under 20 whoa I was like she's a
gon what did she do for a living what
did she do for a living bro that's like
blowing her up right now she has like
her own business what kind of I'm just I
need notes on what to avoid here for the
men and the women I'm um like a cleaning
business oh wow cleaning her face
on so don't date cleaning ladies
okay don't date nurses that's the real
one um yeah I've heard that a lot lady
but I noticed that before I ever saw
that [__] on the internet every single
nurse I met anything that has to do with
[__] medical they're you soong any
girl that has a job
really what if she works from home go
wait wait I got it I got it go not to
work no no I got it go to unemployment
office go to like the farmers market
that's like a spot no I don't know the
farm put on the farm market I can't put
them on like that gonna pay me for that
info okay so what about have you did you
go on a date before that yeah how did
that one go [__] what do we do bro I
don't know there's been a few um just I
think we just went out to dinner like
that was that's like the easy one like
just meet me downstairs go to like
moxy's catua some [__] like that oh
that's cash okay did did you like her
the one before bro like I don't like
going on dates with girls like you guys
aren't interesting like I'm I'm not
trying to be rude but it's like there's
only so much to talk about like I tell
you about the Matrix I tell you about
who runs the
world
iting yourself I give you actually I
need to how okay how do First Dates go
for you you so you you just open up with
well I actually so listen red pill wait
wait it's like the basic [__] like so
like for those of you like there's a lot
of guys that like legit don't know how
to talk to girls there's like the few
basic questions you can do that everyone
can can ask it's like oh where are you
from what do you like you do in school
where you work and like yeah you're not
very entertaining but that gets you by
at least initially and then from there I
don't know I try to like play like um
jokes and build off of those so like I
don't know joke about being like Andrew
Tate taught me how to pimp women and now
you can come join my Army and then we'll
we'll joke about that for 20 minutes I
mean they laugh like they think it's
funny because they probably feel awward
they're like well I mean it's a joke
know but I get what he's trying to say
saying
if what do you do for work and I'm like
I'm a pimp as like I'm obviously not a
[__] pimp do I look like a pimp no I
mean he knows how to play chess we'll
just joke about [__] and then like I
don't know I'll tell them like who runs
the world that kind of stuff who runs
the
world I can't relate to that's what
I you're trying to tell them about the
Deep State and how feminism [__]
Society on the first
day on the first
dat they're not against the Matrix you
can't that's the DAT but you have to
blow their mind a bit so like at the end
of every first date and then they're
laying with me and they're like you
think everything's a scam cuz I'm like
yeah sunscreen's a scam shampoo's a scam
yeah that's [__] [__] like I say
everything's a scam and they're like
What's not a scam you got to show me so
I try to be like their portal to the
truth in a way where I like destroy
their reality in real time they love it
he's fixing women I would have teing
women apart
and I'm just interested he's 10 minutes
I I only need or do you live in Miami
yeah I do now okay how long have you
lived here I mean I've been in and out
of Miami I probably spent about two
three months here at a time and how
when's the last date you went on um few
days ago and how'd it go great what did
she do for a little well actually you
know I don't go on dates I'm you know
I'm staying in my house reading books
you I don't do that but let's say I was
to go on a date wait I would uh I'm a
man of God I don't I don't go on dates
got things to do right now like you know
got to take over the world and whatnot
but let's say I was to go on a date
here's what I would do I would probably
I wouldn't go in like I wouldn't do a
night date since the first date I would
take him out to I don't know a park or
like take him to the beach or just
something in the daytime real nice quick
meeting maybe a coffee 20 minutes asking
about astrology asking about
[Laughter]
whatever girl that though zodiac so you
said you're a man of God are you
celibate yeah yeah of course
wow and so I I assume you're not a very
we talked about it earlier so are you
going to wait until marriage for the
next time then you're G to go all the
way with that oh can't can't disclose
that information I know why not you're a
man of God that's what they do that's
why I can't I can't disclose it you know
between him and God
also between me and God but I also think
men can physically cheat everyone you
guys were talking about men cheating
earlier men can physically cheat
multifaith fness so you a woman can
physically cheat but yeah I mean all
these guys that cheat in Miami they're
not they're not cheating they're just
being multifaith also like your guy
that's not cheating he's jerking off and
he's liking other girls Instagram
pictures if he could get with those
girls I'm actually curious would you
rather your man jerk off to pixels on a
screen or just go [__] some bad [__] he
could jerk offer I catch don't think
that's more pathetic than him like
finding a hot Miami chick and
like I'll help you I'll be back maybe I
also like it's only cheating the
cheating aspect of it like that to me is
not an issue I feel like if a man's
committed to you in a sense that like he
takes care of you he's making sure that
all your boxes are checked like from top
to bottom like especially like in a
marriage or something like that then I
like well if you know about it it's not
cheating then and if the other woman you
say yeah I have a girlfriend like my
issue is when it becomes chea is when it
becomes like disrespectful or like
blatantly like or lying in your well
it's also like you just you don't
respect you lose respect calling your
phone or something that's
a a find line that you shouldn't cross
in a relationship know about it if he
cheats as long as you don't find out not
cheating right like it's not even about
that it's not even about like not
knowing about it because every woman
knows her like when you're in a
long-term relationship for more than 5
years like you know that
you know what they're doing or what
they're not it's just a a matter of
respecting what if I told you sexually
you just never be enough for him ever
that's what I'm saying that's why I
don't have a problem with cheating I
have other [__] to do all right like you
know what I'm saying like I get that I
just want to make sure my issue no when
it becomes cheating is when it's like
blatantly disrespectful when it's
something that like okay let's say
you're no longer preserving the sanctity
of what your relationship is to you like
between the two of you now if you're
honest and you're respectful and
polygamy is your thing and the girl's
down hey sure why not you know what I
mean so we're dating though I can cheat
you can't that's cool right I don't give
a [__] I have other [__] to do all right
cool what does that mean what do you
have to do I have other things to
do no I have a 14-year-old I'm a standup
comedian I a business like I have other
things to do like the first funny woman
standup comedian probably maybe I got to
come watch like I I swear like everying
Tik Tok I see of a woman standup
comedian I want to break my phone I'm a
[__] I'm a [__] I'm that's all they
say they just joke about it I
actually talk about I actually talk
about the fact that like I like seeing
couples together like when I'm out at
shows and I do crowd work I [__] with
couples that are together and I promote
them staying together because dating is
[__]
now you know so why not celebrate making
things work with a person that you're
genuinely compatible with I think that's
another problem is that people just hook
up with people just to hook up with them
and they don't even touch the surface to
see if they're genuinely compatible you
don't think one woman's enough for for a
man I know you mentioned that earlier me
yeah uh well I don't I think one woman
is enough but I think that men always
have a natural instinct to want to have
other girls so if he doesn't exercise
that option he's fighting against his
biology so y i one woman he can he can
suppress it but like it's always in his
mind that he wants to [__] up it depends
what she's giving him as well I feel
like men need that sexual fulfillment
the way women need the emotional
fulfillment right women need their men
to be there for them in certain ways but
if women are willing to reciprocate that
in the form of sexual gratification then
he's definitely going to have a
Wandering eye and you can't blame
anybody but
yourself that you can't stop a wanding
eye no you can't stop a Wandering eye
from wandering so wander it's going to
W always say new [__] that is so what
what's your opinion are you always gonna
have like are you gonna have a bunch of
chicks how's it going to work for you I
mean I think it depends on uh the woman
that you have if she can hold you down
and she's enough then it might for some
men it might be maybe some men they have
not necessarily low testosterone but
maybe they have a low sexual drive and
one woman it is enough maybe they really
love that woman she's the greatest woman
in the world to them and they're just
like they look at another girl and
they're like ew like that that's
possible I mean if you get a bad and you
guys like smash all the time like you
don't feel the I mean this is from my
experience if I've had like consistent
sex with a girl that's really attractive
like 95% of other girls I look at I'm
like you're not even as hot as this one
so why would I even want to put any
effort I don't want to hear your jokes
and I don't want to explain the Matrix
to you I'll just go back to my girl
nobody's talking about the Matrix you
bring it up if You' been if you've been
with the if you've been with a real
woman and you really like her and she
really likes you and you spent enough
time together I think she's more than
enough and uh if you want to cheat and
she's fine with it then sure go ahead
but maybe it's like once a year maybe
it's when you're drunk maybe yeah maybe
just [__] around with her who knows but
the majority of cheating is the majority
of cheating is a one- time thing
though what is I I hear this a lot so
what is a real
woman I would say real woman yeah I
would say a very uh obviously smart you
want someone intelligent if you're a
smart guy maybe you like fun but I guess
it's subjective to everyone but I would
say low body count ideally zero that's
the most important one in my eyes I
would say Obviously smart attractive
because attractive to you at least
subjectively because that is what also
really matters and comes from a good
family also I I would I wouldn't date a
woman unless she came from a wealthy
respected
family they have to be wealthy yeah for
me for me some some guys like they don't
care but yeah are you wealthy
I'm I'm from Pennsylvania if you know
where that's I have two questions one
what's a low body count to you zero yeah
okay so
virgin okay um and why a wealthy family
I it would most likely she would be
raised well versus another you you can
have a girl that's great from a
non-wealthy family I'm just not risking
it coming from a good family and coming
from like they can be they they could be
from a wealthy family but they might not
be they might be like a [__] you know
so you got to like actually meet her
family see if they're good people see if
they rais their right and yeah that's
the main thing is coming from a good and
Wealthy family I feel like it also
eliminates gold diggers as well right
like people who are only going to be
dating you for genuine intentions you
know if they have their family to have
their back they're never going to rely
on it just fixes everything it's just so
like you have a nice wealthy girl from a
nice family all the stuff you don't even
have to teach her anything she just
knows she knows she knows class she
looks great and she keep listen to sexy
red and all this [__] she doesn't have
le le you know but but also I don't
think there's that was that was a low
below I don't think there's anything
wrong I don't think there's anything
wrong with a with a woman dating a guy
for money though just for the record I
don't think that's a problem I i' prefer
dat a woman that doesn't obviously I
don't say doesn't work but also like
wants me to be the bread winner the
provider so you know I I agree with what
you're saying if she has a wealthy
family maybe she'll be uh more likely to
be a better wife but I just think she
has just just has has to have a father
in her life a good family and that's
enough I can kind of take it take it
from
there was gonna ask you that like is it
important for you for them to come from
a two- parent
household yeah that's important yeah
that's valid not necessarily no as long
as they were raised right uh the parents
could be divorced it's not the end of
the
world so I'm curious I want you guys to
raise your hands if these are deal
breakers for you for guys okay all
right all right right two two bodies are
we talking about like a wife or what
yeah we're talking about wife like yeah
wifey wifey okay all right two bodies
deal breaker BR I just want to see okay
10 bodies oh come on that's crazy that's
insane doing your DNA with another woman
two is stretch 10 all right so a wife
seven seven bodies bro like two is the
max all right two so zero two seven
would be
all right five uh five would not all
right tattoos deal break absolutely not
every tattoo is five bodies
minimum like a full sleeve or some [__]
yeah no okay there's tattoo math so if
any back tattoo 20 bodies maybe like you
have a butterfly means you're kind of
basic you might be a bit of an NPC Ask
Gary the numbers guy you might have NPC
energy tra Sam how many the back one bro
that's like 10im don't know the men let
the men talk about their standards
without interrupting thank you now all
right so um t one tattoo done or no so
one tattoo they can get away with I
don't know like if her dad died or
something and she got it on her anle
it's like it's different oh well that's
kind of a red flag too though okay all
right all right we're GNA try this again
raise your hand one tattoo is that a
deal breaker no problem okay two
tattoos three
tattoos four tattoo we got to talk about
square inches cuz like she can have like
that's kind of the point it's like
there's types of tatto it's her tattoos
deal break 100% deal
breaker it's funny so this was actually
for my dad I don't mind that I don't
mind that yeah so like that's more like
wholesome that's a
reason red flag I have one here between
my chest I have one on my thigh and then
I have one by my wrist is that a deal
breaker 100% okay so yeah okay now I
walk with God plastic plastic surgery is
that a deal
breaker yeah plastic boobs are ass my
boobs are plastic i' rather natural but
I mean as long as it looks good right
not a deal breaker deal Breer deal
breaker I don't like the I don't like
plastic like I like natural don't you
feel like you're being catfished out of
like what your future children are going
to look like I don't have a plastic bab
pictures great she's healthy whatever
they'll just be flat I mean yeah it'll
be
fine fig wait guys guys wait wait so
she's very sweet but dumb deal
breaker for a wife I think that might be
a bit of a deal breaker yeah all right
what about you depends what you like if
you're a very very masculine man talk I
know I'm just talking about you no it's
not a deal bre dumb girls are so
annoying you can make them smart it's
not hard to make a dumb girl above
average intelligence of all the other
girls you just teach them okay what
about you teach them but if they're done
they're not going to catch it doesn't
matter I'm smart stop stop I I'm smart
so I don't need her to be smart so she
can be dumb and sweet okay um if she has
a only fans deal breaker come on like
obviously like what the [__] okay what
if it only has bikini pictures on it bro
what the [__] are these Miami questions
like that is the craziest thing I've
ever heard in my life that is from Miami
logic like a lot of my friends here
they're like yeah know she uh she had an
only fans or maybe she just sold titty
pcks in high school it's not that bad
I'm like you [__] insane like that is
a no why was it in high school I I have
more questions if she's been divorced
but no kids I'm 20 like
obviously yeah yeah deal bre deal Breer
uh no not for me I'm 35 I don't a kid uh
yeah deal breaker deal breaker yeah
you're sh you're sharing your DNA with
another man any man that's been inside
of her it's a thing it's called toog me
you're sharing your DNA with that woman
or with that man so if someone else rail
a girl before you you're why do you
think siblings look different whoa okay
well not only are you sharing your DNA
you're pretty much in like a poly
relationship you're in a relationship
with her kid from some other guy and
then you're in a relationship with him
if he's in the kid's life so by default
well that's a different but I'm saying
by default I have to deal with him you
and his and your kid by some other guy
if the dad wasn't involved it would
still be a deal breaker yeah it would
still be a deal breaker what did you
toogy what did you call that that's what
it's called toogy yeah basically another
man heard of that before that yeah I
mean why do you think siblings look
different
interesting siblings look different okay
well let me get this that's a crazy gav
really crazy I'm not even I'm not even
completely doubting what you're saying
but I'm not sure that all the siblings
would look exactly the same do you think
the most powerful thing human sperm is
just going to go away from a inside of a
woman it's meant to be in there it's
going to stay in the wall I'm not even
doub I'm not even doubting that I'm sure
there's something to it but once they're
they camp out they're staying so so
she's a virgin all all the siblings look
exactly the
same not exactly the same but like not
you know one sibling is not going to
have different colored eyes and hair
than another sibling Can it can still
happen it's very rare though but you see
it happen all the time with
siblings my brothers look so different
so
wait use protection um to it doesn't
apply if sorry the sperm never
technically enters her does it apply
then no D with protection yeah so if
she's a safe three or four what if he
comes out every time your mom gets
railed the baby's face
changes the eyes change the nose it
doesn't matter if he has a condom or not
oh my goodness
changes after 100 it turns into like a
[__] like alien yes exactly are there
are there any jobs that are deal
breakers for you guys nurses
nurses no
bartenders oh wow nothing nothing really
I mean after a certain period she
wouldn't work at all but if she wanted
to then sure she can but certain jobs
now like she's obviously not going to be
a uh
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't do a nurse
only fans girl influencer like she
wouldn't do that stuff but bottle girl
yeah for sure yeah anything involving
another man that's around her flirting
with her like you being a PA too I got
some bottle girls over there oh no I'm
not a bottle girl what are you talking
about I saw insurance from home in my
house I'm going to read some professions
and I want you guys to know what it's
like d to come really here as an
investigator no all right all right what
do you actually I didn't even write
these down
what do you guys think of dating
comedians oh they're not funny like
they're not none of them are funny like
I'm sorry wait what was the question
dating comedians comedians like the guy
makes you laugh the only way you can
have a good sense of humor is if you can
um if you're compatible with the guy's
jokes and you get along with them like
it is so rare that a girl makes me laugh
I'm the one that fun I me but you're 22
too so the girls that you're talking
about have no life experience to be able
to have a clear conversation with you
that that that all right that could
totally be a part of it all the girls
I'm talking to they're not
fun they get less funny I think you
think so are you on my side with this
one no because your hum gets darker and
you get like
I you guys think of any female comedians
who are as popular as the number one
male
comedian no feminism trying to think you
know I I know she's kind of rap like
she's kind of like don't really like her
as a person that much um with all the
stuff that she's been in the news for
recently but she Tiffany hadish is kind
of
funny funny I know she did like she was
kind of she was like wild in on her
fiance is she fat no no she was like
usually like fat chicks can be funny
maybe call F I'm just saying chasing
Shakira Shakir TI okay so when was the
last date you were
on uh the last date was like like two
months ago how did it go um it was good
I mean we had sex so I got a one night
stand out of it it was pretty good for
me it was a
score um I mean for me when I'm on dates
I just get the women talking about
themselves I'm usually not listening but
then like eventually I'll like tune back
in and hear what she says and then I'll
be like oh really and then I'll like I
don't actively listen when women are
speaking a lot of times on dates but
what I'll do is I'll catch a part and
then I'll ask her a question on hold and
I'll keep them no but if you just catch
part of it and you keep her talking then
you know you just keep going and then I
just kind of like I don't know I usually
take her somewhere where I can dance or
like something where we can kind of have
some touching going on and then we go
from there what types of women do you
typically date like what do they do um
how old are they usually they're like 23
24 25 in that range um usually they're
like customer service Representatives or
some [__] like they I try to get girls
that are like working regular jobs
looking at me I I don't know what happen
I'm a i insurance Insurance
Brokers insurance I don't leave my house
I work from home 65y old all day long
that's why you don't date cuz you're in
the house all the time um no I actually
go outside to be funny and I was on a
date a month ago and the reason I don't
date regularly is because I'm actually
extremely picky that's not good though
why not she has Aid like bro I have to
be picky I'm not going to just bring a
bunch of dudes to my house have that
[__] them up you not I'm I can't do that
what's wrong with being picky if you
can't have a lot of bodies as a my
daughter I have a how old is the
daughter she's 14 yeah I have I have a
controversial opinion yes I'm going to
give it to you okay yeah I think when
people have kids and they choose to be
single mothers I think shop close down
the shop till they're 18 that's what I
do that's I mean my daughter's never met
another man she knows her dad like I'm
not the
idea
I have other [__] to do you guys yeah
cuz the other guys are the most likely
one no I would never I would never do
that you're a single mother and she's an
only child yeah whoa that I think I said
this yesterday I've never I'll do the
zerka I have never met a single mom that
has an only child that's a girl it's
always a son yeah that's the first time
I've ever met one have you guys noticed
that too it's always the son that's the
only child with the single mom I mean
she has other siblings from her dad oh
okay well then it's my my point stance
to the to the ladies to the ladies that
are single moms though do you realize
like the next relationship you get in
like you shouldn't [__] it up like
you're in the like you need to you need
to realize that you're not the prize why
I'm waiting for the right relationship
what about you you know how I feel about
I've told you a lot about it so I'm
dating somebody we haven't been together
long it's been about 2 months and I mean
we're already talking about me moving to
Utah with my kids and picking up and
going over there by next year so wow how
do you how do you know them um so I was
doing live streaming like just like on
it's this app called no not like that
it's no nudity you literally just talk
to people that's it if you even try to
like if I was wearing this I would get
banned okay so you met him on a live
streaming yeah it's called meet me um so
yeah so I met him on there I was like
talking to my friend we were doing like
were he lives in Utah huh he lives in go
on it before you talk [__] I'm
not how many how many how many times
have you met him um okay so he came from
Utah and we spent four days together now
in two weeks I'm going to Vegas to see
him cuz he's there for work and then
he's going to come back over here then
I'm going to back and forth okay so how
many times have you met him four well
four
days okay so you're considering moving
your kids and your family for a guy you
met this man on Omega girl wild not
going to lie it is wild it is and I
agree it's wild but there's a reason why
I feel comfortable okay okay okay I'm
I'm going to take a note I'm going to
take a note um what my
parents wait wait I need I need to know
so she wants to date or she men in Miami
are I'm going to take my time with like
man in Miami though I hope so at least
he's not from Miami he's not not she
doesn't like men in Miami so much that
she is going to go to Utah girl fly here
there bunch of Mormons there don't worry
no there is he told me about that they
they like do that dipping thing they're
weird but he's not Mormon you know about
the dipping dipping
they what do they dip are you talking
about when they shake the bed hold on
hold on no they di what are they dipping
you don't know about the dipping like
their chips they're dipping their
chips they're dipping their
yeah chip and they just let it they let
the chip just sitting there for like 30
minutes because they can't have sex so
does the DNA go then or
what are we talking too what are we
talking cuz it's kind of
fermenting they just dip they yeah
they they're weird they let it sit for
like 30 minutes that's like yeah it's
weird heard that you just educated me
and that is crazy
disgusting that they do that they like
they'll lay on top of you and then they
just move like the bed they barely move
though that's perfect you can have your
kids jump on the bed while you he's not
a Mormon though all right
so guys guys wait so I have a question
for you so you've met this guy for four
days now you're with him four days
straight we've been talking for two
months straight okay I don't really I
don't really count it unless you're meet
and impressive really unless you're like
I don't I don't I don't think you could
really get to know someone that well
like virtually okay so you met him all
right so how that's how I met the father
please let me finish my sentence so so
how long do you need to speak to him
until you're ready to move I would say
about a year about a year okay so you're
not going that soon no that's why I said
next year one year okay mhm is this
typical for you to meet the guys online
no no I met the father of my kids
through a mutual friend but at the time
that we started talking he was living in
Texas and we were on the phone for 5
months before we met in person and then
we lasted 10 years okay yeah this guy
would call you every day for five months
and we' be on FaceTime the same way that
I do with my man okay what Happ what
happened to get a hobby yeah he seems
like a good dude five months of calling
every day good dude well he turned up to
be an addict and he's in rehab now so
yeah he was a good dude that'll get you
he kept it in secret no um in the
beginning he wasn't into drugs he got
into that during our seventh year when I
got pregnant with our second child and
what typ Dr keeping it for me so it was
percoats then heroin then cocaine he y
yeah I did you find these girls on Omega
where did you get everyone what is Omega
it sounds like that sounds like a dog I
don't recruit it all so I just oh a
recruiter finds yeah they I don't know
what's wrong with us she found you on a
pimp site I know the cup so okay what
about you you haven't been on a date
though so you got nothing I have got
nothing you know anything about dating
in Miami no men you've been okay come on
six months you're pretty girl there's
been no men no I actually I ended up
accidentally on a date okay yes so I it
was it was a fell streamer right we were
we were all hanging out after after
Source cost right we were all hanging
out at the casino and uh a guy was like
Hey like we should you know talk content
we should hang out sometime and so we
made plans to go out to dinner uh he was
running late dinner was taking a while
and so I was like damn there aren't
really going to be any places open
nearby where I'm at um and so he ended
up coming by my place and I quickly
realized within 10 minutes that I am not
cut out for dating unless this guy is an
anomaly but within literally the first
five minutes he let it be known I'm
really interested in you I think you're
very attractive and my intention is to
like have sex not I don't knowable you
are that's what he should do godamn it I
was like I'm not ready to date I'm sorry
like that's what he's supposed to do
guys I want I want the men wait wait
wait wait wait wait I want the men um
raise your hand do you respect that you
respect like her leaving no no no him I
couldn't leave Law too hide your
intentions come on now that's Basics but
you he he needs to know you can do that
if
I mean don't like let know what you're
thinking up front be straight ahead not
like 10 minutes into a date though it
was literally s FSE after being at my
house literally within the first 10
ladies ladies news flash every time we
take you out we want to [__] bro but you
got every time you got to warm up the
leads bro it just turn me off straight
away like any type of like rman or build
up or anything
from back there's no problem what he did
it's just a matter if he didn't have
enough he didn't he to pull it off
basically like if he was your ideal type
and he was the coest guy in the world
and he was like let as [__] You' been
like so it's just it's a man not having
that social cues so there's nothing
wrong with it quickly you got to let it
cook if the girl's like you know 6 out
of 10 interest put on the grill a bit
you know you're right if that was my
type I probably would have everything is
life is a funnel so he had the lead gen
where he got you at this place and then
he needed to send you into the webinar
warm you up get you a glass of wine look
at this everything
let's go I'm a big Advocate on trying he
should have tried it's just what
happened after was it awkward afterwards
did I just said that like I'm not about
that life I've never been about that
life I'm sorry you're probably going to
end up disappointed and so feel free to
leave now if that is your intention
otherwise we can have a drink awward we
say we had a good chat it was nice like
listen were you attrac to no not really
okay so in a way it almost like helps
him save time exactly
for sure if you were attracted to him
would you have entertained him well what
I will say is I have actually dated guys
who I was not attracted to originally
but because I got to know them
more of them that made me more
attractive to them so I could have been
attracted to him had I got to know more
of his traits without first being like
have you dated guys that you were also
attracted to like right away only one
actually okay yeah do you see how she
like lights up when
she literally like which guy he was he
was gorgeous oh my God he was like the
only guy of data that was prettier than
me he was
gorgeous
to kind of we I don't think we were like
very mentally compatible he was like a
very
surf he was a year younger than me he
was Aussie and he was like a surfer
skater dude but he was so beautiful my
god do you see how she like lit up this
is
why and why do you guys keep saying this
is but I'm GNA explain something to you
this is why and I don't ADV for this but
this is kind of why the guys will say
like you have to sleep with the girl
right away because it's like they want
the girl that's like oh my God instead
of the girl that's like I'm going to
warm up to you kind guess maybe yeah
that makes sense I mean for guys that
validates a lot of you know when they
see a woman who's so attracted to them
that is a huge validation for a guy like
that's what they're they they don't want
a girl who is like wishy-washy on them I
feel like it's kind of yes and no cuz
then like there's there's good-looking
dudes everywhere realistically so if
you're liking me like just for my looks
and I didn't have to put in all that
work and like all these other accolades
that I built up about myself didn't
affect the end result then that means
that like the same thing could have
happened for another guy so if you had
to really get to know me better and a
lot more I personally think it ends up
meeting more in the end so you prefer
that actually yeah I I mean for like a
wife yeah like I think like having to
warm up to you more I I mean that's why
you got to build up to it I don't you
understand my what I'm saying you want a
wife with yeah like I don't really
believe that much in like the oh we made
eye contact like who else you make an
eye contact with them [__] that's
[__] you think what do you guys
think about um because I know some
podcasts have this like she doesn't
sleep with you on the first dat get rid
of her sort of stuff what do you think
no it just it depend it depends on the
girl you heard that on fres F before
yeah they're ex I'm not saying that I'm
just asking your opinion go ahead it
just depends on the girls some girls
maybe it's the third fourth date you
could do everything right be her perfect
type she could love you so much it could
be the third or fourth date some girls
it's on the first date it doesn't mean
they're a [__] or anything sometimes
they just like you that much you guys
really clicked maybe went out maybe
drank a little bit I don't they all
these guys want to put all this number
like third date 4.5 date she should [__]
by like it's just it's [__] it
doesn't matter it really doesn't matter
you why you
think make sure you're talking yeah just
grab would you would you take a girl
serious if you slept with her on the
first date like I would it wouldn't be
ideal but it depends how it happened if
I'm like railing her in the bathroom at
like a bowling alley then yeah probably
be like you know probably be different
but if I don't know if we were maybe we
went on our first date and we were on
like a trip or something or you know you
flew out or something like that then
yeah it's like normal you know isn't it
kind of deceiving though sometimes if
men like some men expect women to go on
the first date and then expect and then
like some men deceive the women to have
sex on the first date but also want
women to have small small amount of
bodies when other men are fooling them
that's true that's true it just depends
it depends on the situation like if
you're flying girls out you're probably
going to [__] the how many how many like
times you got to be fooled I mean the
men are pretty the men are pretty
generous nowadays like I mean I'll when
I am on these shows the average number I
get for Wifey this is on the low end but
it's typically around 10 so you get 10
fools wow that's and here's the thing I
don't know I don't know your body count
and I'm not going to ask cuz I do think
that's kind of a weird question but like
you have that guy where your face lights
up now every 10 bodies there's like two
more of those guys that gets added on so
now here we are where you one of you has
I don't know 20 bodies and now there's
four other dudes that every time you
think about them it lights up in your
head and that is the worst thing that a
guy could could be possible imagine your
girlfriend being like oh yeah that
Aussie Surfer like he so good looking
imagine that's imagine that's like you
know your wife and like so you know
someone ask her about it yeah my face
may have lit up but what I will say is I
have never like thought about that guy
during intimate moments but the one the
one I'll say separ is if your future
husband watches this pod and sees that
say he's dead to you he's dead to you no
lighting up the face no blinking quickly
but they would be I wouldn't marry
somebody who didn't like induce that
response for me at least I would hurt if
I wouldn't I mean it's like drugs after
like the 10th time you won't get as much
of a light up but the first time you're
like yeah yeah so so the men will give
you a couple fools they'll give you 1 2
3 4 5 6 seven eight me you get zero okay
not you guys I'm just telling you from
doing the shows that's the most common
number I get it's like interesting 10ish
from the
guys sense so so so um with that it's
like after 10 they're like hell stupid
are you yeah but realistically most like
I'm sure most women in here or no women
in here are virgins so we don't really
have much to pick from like most women
are going to have bodies like you just
got to pick from what you what you can
get like do you think you'll find a
virgin Someday my girlfriend's a Muslim
virgin and 18 years old so she's Muslim
so so that's okay that makes more sense
religious is I actually I have questions
because a lot of men are looking for
those so where would you find one like
how would you find
her well you can do two ways you could
go on Instagram should I give them the
sauce you got just
run okay you can okay there's two ways
you can go on Instagram pay for that
info I mean say it all right you go on
Instagram and and a lot of guys are out
there morons they just think they're
going to DM some girl with 200k
followers she's GNA answer you what you
do is you go to that 200k follower girl
and you go through her following and
through that following there's going to
be a few [__] that have private
profiles you click on it if they look
hot follow them they accept and follow
you back then you DM them if they don't
follow you back unfollow them right away
in between you got to add some guys in
there you know act like you're not
falling a bunch of girls in a row
anyways that's one way the second way
would be just luck and in in person I
remember my girl at a restaurant saw her
go to the bathroom went up like a real
man introduced myself and that's that's
it oh so you just got that se so wait
hold on on so you can this is how you
find virgins you're saying
that oh so how how do you have a
guarantee that she was a virgin if you
didn't know her your her whole life you
can look in their eyes simple well yeah
you could you behind the eyes well there
could be the physical aspect of you know
and then there also can be
the you know okay some guys might not be
able to decipher it if you've been with
a good amount of girls you know a girl
can't lie about being a virgin she could
maybe lie about come oh you would be
surprise I don't know I feel like you
but if you're a smart man within a year
it would come out maybe I'm wrong but
like I'd rather ignorance is bliss maybe
I'm wrong but I they're also very naive
like my mom gets mad when I say this but
like I can convince a girl I'm psychic
and like I already know the answer so
you have to tell me the truth and it's
like I get it every time I think he's
Friday I want to I want to hear from the
chicks do you know any women that have
lied about being virgins yes
yeah yeah okay did they get away with it
um I well what I was going to say is I
feel like most women lie so why I mean
the I know why men prioritize the body
thing but how do you guys like you
there's a girl you can date a girl from
like a neighborhood you've never been in
that had sex with the whole neighborhood
and then came to your city and has one
body and lied how How would how would
you like you just like they by the way
that you behave the way you behave the
way you carry yourself the way you some
girls are good at acting innocent bro no
you're
not I don't think so it comes out when
you're having sex it comes out when
you're I'm just curious so raise your
hand if you think a chick could hide
that for Life
way
not for I think the truth comes out
eventually we'll test that maybe for a
little you know and you have your kid
and your kid's got like red hair or
something or the kid like yeah you'll
know kid comes out black I'm giving my
kid genetic test I'm going to make sure
100% my goodness oh god wow how do you
wait wait wait because a lot of the guys
are going to want to know about this how
you can do a genetic test to see if your
kid's mother had previous sexual
partners this is a real thing maybe I
honestly don't know okay I thought
that's what you were saying I'm G to
figure it out I I'll check it up when I
have a kid I'm G to figure it out but
I'll look in their eyes I know a lie
detector test question should it should
it be mandatory that every kid that's
born there be a DNA test oh think so
yeah why not people I think so would the
ladies be offended by that like would
you would that make you mad think it's
mandatory but I wouldn't be offended I
would love to like oh you guys would
100% be offended what
wait I said it for the guess what per
wait wait guess what percent of um
pregnancies are actually fathered by a
different kid and this is a lowend wait
what but like like they lied to the man
yeah lied to the man guess what percent
so guess guess what do you think yes and
this is the low end because there's some
numbers that are I'm gonna give you guys
the conservative estim go ahead say 10
10 that's a crazy four jeez no I said 40
uh let's say
22 22 wow okay what do you think I'm
going to say it's like 30 33 Okay that's
14.5% 14 bro I'd say like 5% there's no
way person
that yeah like what what country we
talking what percent of baby daddies or
baby mamas lied about their baby daddy
that's did I just do like the whole
Maybe daddy uh probably like 5 10% I
wouldn't say okay go ahead maybe like
10% okay just from the way that you
introduced it I know it's a crazy number
it has to
be I'll give you guys I'll give you guys
the number so conservative low-end
estimates are around
5% there's a good amount of people that
would say 10% and actually out of DNA
testing center so the people that go get
their DNA tested it's actually one out
of three wow
that's an important part of that
statistic is who's going to get tested
like that's
AR the other way is there's many men
that are oblivious and
don't so that's what I'm saying that's
why that's why I gave you all three
that's why I said it's between five and
33% so but if that if I was a guy then I
would just that's why I think it should
be mandatory personally I know a woman
who had like she was with a guy had a
baby within he raised her kid for years
and it ended up not being his she knew
one wow which messed up how did he find
out he got attested I don't remember how
they found out oh yes he had when the
baby started growing up it didn't look
like him so then he did a DNA test saw
the baby was at his house and found out
it wasn't his so sad so she wasn't my
friend actually I was friends with him
he check on him he he was and the little
boy's name was named after him and
everything you guys do you guys yeah
emotional
damage he did her big
one stay do you guys think a woman like
that should go to jail for fraud raise
your hand if you think yes up after
years because when you look at civil
when you look at civil litigation right
you sue based on the damages incurred so
if a man is spending 203 50 $100,000 on
a child is he is entitled to that
compensation
1,000% pical
damage I mean he probably didn't know
any better but he should it's like one
of those things so I mean it
everything's a man's fault when a woman
does something when your partner does
something it's your fault it's not she
could I don't know get in a car crash
it's your fault you shouldn't let her
drive that day I mean in that in that
position I think that was definitely her
fault she's the one who knew she had he
pied the ho she probably had the back
tats and he didn't
he have back it's an unfortunate
situation but it stems down to being his
fault men have to take accountability
when does Men's like um intuition come
in like ever like in cuz women I can
smell things
sometimes I know women have a really
good intuition that it's always been
said but I've always been curious about
like where men's intuition comes into it
it depends on the man some men like one
of my jobs is telling if people are
scumbags or not so I I'm like I'm all
sensed up I for the past three years i'
I've known I lived in La too if you
lived in La you probably a very good
judge of character because everyone's a
jackass there so some men it just
depends some men are like idiots you
know I have a I have a funny thing we're
going to do with that information after
I get through you to so tell me about
your last date my last date yeah um it
was when I spent the four days with my
boyfriend so we went to the beach we
went out to eat and we got a hotel we
stayed there for 3 days and did like a
bunch of things on the beach like we
just went like oh this guy's from Utah
though yeah gives me no information on
Miami next oh you want somebody from
Miami I mean I can tell you the person
okay yeah tell tell me the last day of
Miami I'm learning about Miami today go
ahead go ahead
um okay my last damn before him it was
uh oh
damn that was
very okay
um what so this goes back to what she
said um an
entrepreneur aggressive honestly do you
want to be honest with you it was me
riding around in the car with him down
Miami just running errand and we went to
get lunch and I just spent the day with
him okay and did you what and you didn't
like that so no second day um I didn't
like what he did for living I didn't
like yeah scammer scammer I didn't like
what he did for living scammer what he
do what did he do actually curious he
was an entrepreneur
entrepreneurs okay I need a raise of
hands who here has dated a scammer
before raise your hand common in miam
wow it's very it's very very common here
and women love and you ladies love these
guys because you realize they were scam
did you know going into the date that
they were scamming you think when she
was at Vendome she was like b g
no there's people in Miami who actually
make money as well so did you guys know
he was a scammer when he took you out um
I think I started getting like just
getting scared every time I left my
like I'm like what kind of scams are
they running I don't
know was he scamming grandma's or like
what was he doing they would never get
into he had Amazon gift cards didn't he
ask you what bank do you have away
Insurance wow wow wow I've never been
asked for yeah I've never been asked for
my okay tell me all right what about you
so my last day I went to go play mini
golf and then after I went to go eat
tacos and then we went back to T and
what did this gu what did this guy okay
wait what did this guy do for a living
oh he's a doctor he was a doctor okay
and are this is the situation scammer
yes
okay um what kind of doctor is he um for
anesthesia yeah okay all right so
doctors and you like him so so we like
the doctor did he buy those good stuff
by what no I got
these him yeah oh okay it's been yeah
month and a half good question so what
did you say you said you're good at at
reading people deciphering yeah okay you
want to go
around do what what am I deciphering
deciphering yeah I want I just want to
see how good he is I want to see how so
did they give their body count
before is it body count what am iing I
don't know I just I wanted to see this
trick of yours it just sound character
Jud you're really good at reading people
whatever I was just curious yeah like
yeah like I do like mentalism stuff but
like that's like magic tricks but I'm
talking about like yeah just I would
have to like you know maybe we have to
have like a little interview sit down I
could okay do you'll do it I'll do it
I'll try okay look you're
toxic and you're not funny you're not a
funny comedian how do you know that
you've never seen you haven't made one
joke all night you're delusional I
haven't talked you date a whole bunch of
[__] scammers and drug
dealers I'm so delusional you're an
enigma I don't know what's going on with
you you're from Australia
and you like black guys never been with
a black guy my whole life actually
that's one
of he was really Hing
Australia I tried to manifest it it
didn't work
I tried to manifest it it didn't work
get there later you have a really nice
pair of tits I love your tits uh wait
that's it oh wait wait I'm sorry sorry
sorry you have to get something I was
confused
um he got extracted on this one no cuz
honestly I I think that you're you're
way too hopeful I think this guy in Utah
is not going to work out for you I think
you're in Miami and you're going to
you're going to meet a scammer I've had
enough of scammers and [__] [__]
[__] and the last one she's a
[__] gold digger she's a gold digger
yep I don't know what you're talking
about
yep yep you heard it here
first wrong you concur how do the
guys I mean you want to do the guys yes
she asked go
ahead the guys
yeah and tell me here yeah he's oh I
have a good one I think he's um he's
fairly new at the he's young so maybe
heus he's
upcoming wisdom doesn't always come with
time I mean doesn't always come with age
it comes with experience so I feel like
I've had a lot of life experience and a
lot of the [__] I've said tonight has
been facts I'm going to stick by okay
you seem like a Sagittarius but I think
you're just very I'm Prett I I'm
Catholic faed faced no I think you're um
very intellectual very a good speaker um
maybe not too much experience with women
cuz you're you said you're elit and I
was just [__]
around and you I think you're like a
really nice
guy but sometimes you act you just you
act like like you're you just you have
to have a tough ex the or so nobody she
likes the black sof I'm not a softy I'm
not a
I'm a good I don't think men I don't
think men that are nice are soft I'm
sorry let me Rea I think you're just
nice and and sometimes with around other
people you know not I mean I don't know
like you put up a is that what you're
trying to say do you guys have thick
skin I want I have another game I want
to play you guys have thick skin
everyone okay I want yeah okay I want to
know from the girls which guys you would
be most likely to go on a date with and
I'm gonna do vice versa later all right
so raise your hand most likely
um I'm old than you're asking me 27 what
do you mean
um yeah yeah so I'm G I'm gonna point
and then you can give give me your
feedback if you'd go on a date or not
and why yes or why no wait can you you
should do the guys first because there
that way they're not going to be biased
in their section you know what I mean
cuz they'll be biased no no no we're
going to we're going to do this the way
I said thank you all right so all right
so they're going to be bias still yeah
all right what do you guys think too
young who would who would you're 20 19
22 22 who would who would eliminate him
just based off his age me ow BR yeah I
mean like that's obvious
that's yeah until the cameras are off
and you should have
lied I should have said 30 how wait how
old do I look how old could I pull off
you look very young yeah you look young
you can't go past 24 the oldest you can
be 24 25 I'm 22 if you said you were 26
27 everyone would have old do you think
I am I'll tell
after tell right
after I'll tell you you're right after 2
27 26 or you might be like 21 or 22 I
almost think you're younger though I
mean they're good friends so they proba
for your age but you're younger oh you
don't no you guys should all right 24 24
oh let's wait okay you're mature for
your age but you're would you go on a
date with him you would if weit are we
choosing we have to choose between the
three or no anyone you would go on a
date or the guy in the bathroom like so
we don't have to go on a date with
anyone oh God please just just you're
making you're making it way more
difficult than if you would go on a date
with him raise your
hand can you I think I'm too experienced
you're too experienced I'm not CIT don't
worrying around oh no cuz you like
virgins so that's why oh yeah oh my gosh
none of you really for me the age thing
the age but you don't even know how old
he is they're closer to my daughter's
age than they are me I can't do you guys
know his
age bro this is they don't know his
age okay I can tell everyone after
but okay I said okay no one would no one
what what's the what's the they like
black guys like I guess I got to get my
inches off it's not out of you three
it's just in general it's just in
general okay I would say didn't you
raise your hand you said you would go
because I thought you would say out of
the three of them but you
said okay what's the what's the what's
the hold up why not I just want to know
why like you guys eliminate a guy well
there're mine now well yeah he's cool
but it's just the age but has yeah I
like his his humor he's he's funny he's
yeah you're gonna get laid after this
for
sure okay okay what and I'm gonna have
you guys do it to the girls too so what
what about him can't be trusted he's
cool really one day no wow what what
have too many one night stands AR three
you single
mothers I mean said for me I understand
what you're saying but for me age is a
big factor I can't date somebody that's
closer to my daughter's age I invited
you and you this is our first date so
we're already on a date right now how
about that I think he very smart don't
know all right what all right how old
are you uh 22 2 what the hell I said 21
said 24 was my final answer but you
could 27 I could pass sure okay so now
we're going to go around and you guys
get to tell me if wife material or
no I asked I asked thick skin everyone
said yes all right wife wife material
yes or no tell me why no or yes think I
start yeah for tonight she'll do you I
have to go on a few more days materal
though so it's a no no no yeah you just
go around give feedback go ahead oh my
God I mean you have a kid that's like
you know I could play football with so I
think we're good on that one no actually
it's a girl so I forgot forgot
girl I don't know you said like two
words all night you're very pretty
though I don't know much about you you
we have a date after this we already
talked about it off camera you
um yeah I don't know you're a tougher
one but I'd say we could go on a couple
Cho Tre dates you know figure it out uh
and then you guys um I'm sorry why guys
what could what could what could they do
to get a date with you anything bro like
go in a time
machine I don't know okay what about you
guys like you guys don't like me cuz I'm
younger and like you guys are older I'm
not trying to be rude or nothing but
it's like no everyone said right we're
all okay right yeah yeah okay what about
you I just go
[Music]
around you're just too old anything like
yeah but uh also the tattoo but very
pretty girl and I like your hair
but I still wouldn't go on a date with
you same thing not just not really my
type uh you're Australian so definitely
not um yeah I wouldn't too old the last
two i' would say right what about you
uh no because you're older I date
younger women exactly um no just no
um you is there anything she could do to
like improve uh
I mean she's dressed modestly what
question are the fingernails are those a
deal breaker for you guys no those are
actually like I like those actually you
like the stripping Nails no no maybe
that like is a little
bit scratch your back and [__] it's
actually nice he's cooking right now no
the back scratch come on give them two
inch longer though um no those are
longer fine two inches is enough right
um so so so no I wouldn't no and why I
don't know I just you're not my type
you're not my type you're you're all
right though you're all right um
her she doesn't like black guys so I
can't really [__] with her like but I do
I would date you I would date you the
problem is that you haven't been on any
dates so I feel like it would be awkward
and weird and we wouldn't really it's
your job to lead the date though would
be been on at least 10 but she said she
she said she went on a date and then
like she bailed because it was weird all
have sex with me in the first 10 minutes
God damn
it crazy how you s every date sir uh I
ask in five minutes oh my goodness no no
no seriously um no I would I would it
has to be at least like three or four
dates I wouldn't ask in the first 10
minutes um you no but you have great
tits and
you no you're a gold digger I'm a gold
digger she's a gold digger she's a gold
digger and this is why the men and the
women can't get together it's like no no
love on this show sometimes people find
love you know no way we need a new
recruit we need a time
machine you can't go to back
though okay so what is your craziest
Miami dating story starting here
craziest Miami dating story
um iend end up at Liv in a pair of
sneakers in a baseball cap at where on a
Sunday at
Liv air of how that crazy one of the
main clubs out here so that's all you
were wearing no I mean I was you had
pants well that's not crazy yeah this is
why is it crazy no yeah what makes it
the craziest date though um woman and it
was like fun like I don't I'm telling
you I don't really have crazy dating
experiences like that
because I'm a different age age bracket
like it's different like dating is
different at this level you know
so craziest dating story in Miami um it
was like ended up being a whole day
ended up as well in booby trap booby
trap is another club late night didn't
walk out so booby trap is open 24/7
strip club it's a strip club here in
Miami I love strip club but booby trap
is open 24/7 so we didn't walk outside
till it was like 8: in the morning did
you grab some stripper ass of course
there you go I want to um all right
she's been to a strip club one time wife
C could you still
wife I've taken dates to strip clubs
okay I'm just yeah I've taken girls on
Dat to strip club I don't have any crazy
Miami I have a crazy New York story I
really
one no it has to be dating dating story
let's go go ahead Miami only okay if New
York is crazy go I mean it's look really
crazy I'm only bringing it cuz it was
crazy go go go A guy stole a car picked
me up from work you told me this right
and then he was speeding like laughing
speeding man man manically the police um
followed us and then they stopped us and
he said watch this and he drove off that
was not a date that's why I don't want
to supposed to be a date that's why I
wouldn't date her cuz you like that
crazy [__] I'm good on that yeah maybe I
haven't had a lot of crazy experiences
but it wasn't my fault he picked me up
from a stolen
car that's a right never happened to me
I
got I
know I've never had this
experience a scammer that sounds
possible to Miami he wasn't a scammer I
really don't know what job he had he was
a robber he
robbed my bad my bad she was subpoena
for that
tap what about you it's kind of a weird
it's like weird telling this on a
podcast but [__] it um you know how zuro
late to like absolutely everything so we
were supposed to do um like in um what's
it [__] called like I don't know e
dates or something at sneo house and so
I was waiting downstairs with the two
girls for like three hours waiting for
zurka to show up and my game is too
strong so obviously like one of them was
mine by the end of the night and so then
I ended up securing the job off camera
what was supposed to be an e dat on sneo
stream oh really so you like hooked up
with her yeah before they even got there
for the date no like we just like went
back to mine and chilled okay
wow that's a great great first date that
was happy it was better than streaming
[__] that wait count okay what yeah so I
had this girl come on a date we went out
with my boy and he's like very very very
intense like he gave me a five hour
history less night last night wouldn't
let me leave he just never stops like he
just likes to argue and he's very
intense and we went out to dinner didn't
say a word to her like she was just
chilling having food whatever went to a
cigar lounge after and he just like
argue with her for like an hour like
intense intense arguing like very there
for this very very intense and like
basically was like making her like cry
and I kept trying I kept trying to like
like change the convers I'm not mad at
him she's just a little bit emotional
but I was trying to call I was trying to
calm everyone down change conversation
he just kept going because he has like
issues anyway so like we're you know she
had a little bit to drink and she was
really sad and we were walking back and
she like got on a flight with these like
random guys in the street and then I had
to go over and like grab her and like
was really bad and
yeah that sounds depressing yeah it
wasn't good he was going too hard with
the that or no I'm a man of God oh my
God I had to be there for time of need
right I saved her from getting like
ATT um I took a girl out we went out to
like [__] Windwood pilos which is
like a [__] Art District here in
Miami um and she was like y you're a DJ
I'm like yeah come back check out my
studio and end like [__] her while I
was DJing I was like switching songs and
[__] it was pretty cool like she was
giving me head like in a public place no
no no no well that's happened before but
that wasn't a date so I work at a strip
club and strippers will like come up and
just like grab my dick or like give me a
head that's happened before but this was
a girl that I went out with wait just
like in public well you so so in the DJ
booth you can only see from here in the
DJ booth you can only see from here up
so if there's a girl down did they try
to char you
but I'm the toxic the river that's crazy
was this at the river this is that this
is that this is at booby trap Dal this
is that a different but you can't see
but what I'm saying is my date was a
girl that was like oh you're a DJ she's
like oh my dat and I was like oh come
back to the studio and we started like I
started playing her favorite songs while
I was [__] her it was pretty cool wow
yeah wow you already heard it yeah yeah
yeah yeah what about you crazy dat yes
get judge but okay it was a date but it
was somebody I was in a relationship for
10 years that still count yeah sure um
we went to a swingers
club wait okay I don't I don't know much
about swingers so what is what is a
swingers so the reason my men don't
cheat on me is because I cheat with them
we do it together cuz I sexually
attracted to women so if my man wants to
be with a woman let's do it together oh
which girl do you find the hottest here
I was about to ask who would
you have you guys like scissored are you
guys are you guys friends
already
metast okay so so do everyone like out
of out of these four who you go on a
date
with like who would I go on a date with
yeah have you ever dated women yeah I
have and where do you tell me the
differences between dating men and
dating women um
women what do you mean like emotionally
sexually what what is the difference
between being in a relationship with a
man and a woman a man um he takes
control I let him take control I let him
lead I like doing that with the woman
because it is to women it's kind of more
you got to compete for that submissive
title or compete for who's leading and
it's kind of like way deeper when you
get into an argument with another woman
cuz like I can slap you you know and it
can get physical and then it gets ugly
but with the man I'm not going to put my
hands on him so would you say that the
girl girl relationships they're the more
violent ones or like more wow for sure
for
sure and you have more arguments when
it's a girl girl I'd assume because
you're fighting for the I mean I've had
a lot of sexual relationships with women
but as far as relationships I've only
had two and both of them were pretty
submissive to me like I was the more
leading one which is weird cuz I'm like
you know so like girly in my nature how
do the swingers clubs work that's like
you do couples go there and they just
like swap no not it wasn't with other
couples we would go on single ladies
night so it was on yeah so it was on
Wednesdays and then Wednesdays only
single ladies and couples are supposed
to be there okay so you go in you get
this membership bracelet you change into
a robe there's like sweets there you
pick a girl or she comes up to you and
you and your man I have I have a story
about this huh has right there it's in a
site there wow they do this you can take
them home but there like room there
Hotel you're not going to want to bring
back to your that's your guy safe yeah
but I need a little intimacy like with a
female I mean that's what it is though
like you go into it's like literally
like if I walk you into that bad bed
like back bedroom you know what I mean
and then you put a busy sign on the door
so like nobody comes in and you lock it
and then you're just in there as
as what was your St yeah yeah I I've
been to a swinger hotel on accident once
Hotel me me and my girlfriend show up
this hotel my friend [__] with me and
I said what are the best hotels in in
and Cancun and he's like yeah bro
Secrets is it's the best trust me it's
the best I'm like all right so I text
the assistant the assistant books it it
was like expensive too so I was like oh
that must be nice my assistant books it
we show up at like 1100 p.m. at night me
and my girlfriend we walk in and we're
just like why is everyone so [__]
weird here we get to like the front desk
and thank God we get there and they're
like yeah um everyone has to be 21 to
like so so we couldn't stay cuz my my
girlfriend didn't have like fake idea or
anything but everyone around us was like
eyeing us up and like waving and [__]
some guy was like throwing up in the
corner like don't go to don't go to
swing regarding this topic I want I
earlier we spoke about how I believe
that all men cheat so and then you said
um that you think it's impossible for a
man to for one woman to be enough right
so do you think a woman that is with a
man and she gives him threesums is that
man more likely to not cheat on her some
will still cheat uh yeah I think if you
give him thre Sims it's more likely that
he would not want to [__] other girls
why do you got to do it one thre sus it
sounds so AIDS like why would you want
to it sound to AIDS like why protection
that's rule number one no I mean like
AIDS and like this is AIDS like like
like you have to like you have to handle
Zoomer saying this oh you guys don't
know what AIDS is like like if something
sucks you're like this is
AIDS never heard old I made it up how
old are you you're I'm 28 I was like I
was like I feel
old I'd rather just [__] a girl 5 minute
break get some raw milk from the fridge
and then come out and [__] another girl
like I don't want to have some threesome
yeah like refuel you know i' I'd rather
have a threesome I mean I'm I'm I mean
I'm cool with it if my girl wants to
have one can I ask the fellas a quick
question though is it cheating if your
girl cheats with a woman well obvious
well all all women are lesbians or lugs
lesbian that's what I'm saying like
would you be pissed if your girlfriend
came back and said hey I just like
hooked up with this girl
yeah yeah it is but they are all
lesbians at the end of the day so if
they find another girl attractive it's
like whatever I think gay stuff is gross
I actually have a funny story my cousin
is gay yeah
just I mean that that just happened to
my cousin like he found out or not my
cousin some guy I know but yeah his
girlfriend went to a bar and she like
munched some girl out and yeah he broke
up
that yeah like I think that's disgusting
like cuz like what are you going to do
with the girl like if you're not going
to make out there's only so much [__]
you can do and like that's kind of gross
at the bar it's also it kind of shows
something about your character like
that's not the kind of girl I'm going to
be dating that
would a bar I'm still stuck on that she
did it at the bar on the girl at the
bar okay raise of raise of hands who
would let their guy if they like the guy
enough they're going to let them do
three sums with you raise your
hand put them high so you like chicks
too no but I I would prefer that for my
man yeah I would prefer that for my man
versus him cheating and I would be I
mean girls are beautiful I'm not
attracted to them but they're gorgeous
you know women are way more just a fun
time I you know I would like just rather
not
like like I'm not looking you want to
watch him screw another chick I just
feel like there really pretty girls know
by but there's some really pretty girl
you don't know till you try Pearl you
don't know till you try I just so you
don't know till you try how do you know
might turn it might turn you on she's
like super pink she was like listen was
like gross
anyways yeah I would I would I would in
Pearl's World I'd ban all the gay stuff
oh yeah I would ban it I would be honest
it was when I was seven years in that me
and him sat down and had a talk and I
was like listen we've been together
seven years if you're going to be with
me another 10 years I don't expect you
to only be satisfied with me so if you
want to do it let's do it together and
we had that conversation if I had to
pick one like if I had if I had to pick
threeome or He Cheats I would just
rather the cheating I swear to God I
don't watch let have a sister wife no
I'd rather just not no you know what a
sister wife I'd rather have neither I'd
be
honest if it's up to me you know but the
cheating is preferred if I had to pick
one L that I look I believe once you
have kids it's not about you anymore
you don't have so right now you know I'd
really prefer to be with a guy who
wouldn't you know I think every girl has
a guy that they would like enough that
they'd put up with it let's just be
let's just be real would I prefer it no
but um yeah I think once you have kids
like yeah you're stuck stay right I know
I'm stucking with you
talk four
days four days in person you may not
consider it but I feel like that's how
like I literally fall asleep on the
phone with dude bro like little kid [__]
like when I'm back in sounds like a
craziest craziest date you've been on
I'm still thinking about it you've had
all table the thing I know I'm still
like what is she's going through all of
them okay okay okay well I think it was
more bad in my part because I kind of
like passed out oh wait what yeah I
passed out okay okay okay so funny story
I we went we went to go watch a movie
then we went to go eat and drink and
like I'm just I'm not really of of a
drinker I usually smoke so you know it
got to me and then I was like I'll be
right back I'm going to go to the
restroom I kid you not fell asleep on
the [__]
listen listen listen I passed out in the
bathroom saw between the legs listen no
I was there for like 30 minutes no thank
god well no yeah I was pretty much there
and then like 30 on the song yeah and
then he's looking for me and he's like
knocking all the stars and then I woke
up and he was like oh my God are you
okay I was like you're probably scared
that man Jesus but you know what to this
day he's still fanatic he's like how how
are you when when you want to catch up I
was like no I was too embarrassed after
wow so you never hit oh he didn't no I
didn't hit no because I was already like
no I have a question who's been in Miami
longer than a year oh I've lived I was
born and raised in Miami okay who's been
here longer than two years three years
oh you guys still okay okay so we're
going to go into past relationships
regardless I just kind of wanted to get
a sample size here do you have an ex
that's the one that got
away yeah I do okay what was he like
what was he like yeah
um he was a genuinely great great guy um
I would say he kind of like checked off
all the boxes
physically um it was
also uh a sense in that like we shared a
lot of the same values like as to what
we saw like our future or like what we
want out of life like at this point um
with him it was just a distance Factor
okay and how long were you with him uh I
want to say like a year and a half and
how old were you when you dated him uh
uh this was two years ago three years
ago okay so semi- recent yeah okay what
about you um I would say no only because
they still want me for how they didn't
get away he
got so no there's no ex you regret
breaking up with you miss oh I mean
regret breaking up with but they they
didn't get away because they I could
have them okay so what's stopping you
from getting back with him just like one
factor about them to controlling oh he's
too what did he what did he try to
control
um oh gosh I was in my era where I
wanted to hang out with friends a lot
and that was a noo okay so was it female
friends or male friends fale okay so
where were you guys hanging out the club
of yes for sure okay so but I believe if
it's a girl's birthday she invites me
out okay okay so you there's only one
birthday a year you picked all so and
what was how 52 friends a bunch of
celebrations if my girl gets a promotion
we're going to celebrate okay okay so
you picked the club over a
boyfriend Club my friends
really the club with your friend that's
what I'm just repeating the club with my
friends y over the boyfriend yeah okay
and he still wants to date you yeah okay
what what does he what does he do for a
living he's um armed security so he's a
security guard yeah okay that makes
sense all right next not going nowhere
you guys don't even know where like they
do security but it's cool does he do
security somewhere we should know about
yeah yeah it's not regular security okay
what what type of security for
celebrities and things like that so he
he's a security guard for what
celebrities I'm not going to disclose
that information okay so big celebrities
I'm guessing yes okay the president and
I was like it was the president the
biggest celebrity okay next um no I
don't think any of my exes got away I
think um my exes were like lessons in my
life to be honest to teach me how to be
ready for the right guy cuz I think
after the relationship I was way more
nurturing I understand men's mind a
little more but no you
don't I've never I have never seen a
woman in my life get better with age
ever so I just I I just I doubt but do
you think that you think there's like um
I've never I've died you don't think
everybody as a human is like able to
like just grow mentally I know I'll tell
you what to grow mentally I think men
grow mentally I think women we just kind
of get worse so how come some men never
want a woman that like is intellectually
on their level if they're growing
mentally like we women look they don't
they don't want women that think they're
smarter than they are because usually
women aren't that smart yeah I mean men
like to teach you things too like they
like to show you well men aren't that
smart either I thought women I thought
women had men are like a bronchos saurus
they're either really smart or really
dumb and then women are just I don't I
don't believe that I think they lie I
think they fake the IQ test and there's
some evidence that supports my theory it
is a theory but I'll tell you yeah
because basically a lot of the IQ
questions on the test became more
ideological in the 80s 70s and they
waited things higher like writing and
English that tend to favor more towards
women that's my argument I I just don't
believe I think IQ tests in general are
just [__] it's just some [__]
words that they try to put IQ things but
anyways sorry keep going how about um
okay if you came from like a divorced
family and you didn't really have a good
example of relationship and then growing
while you had relationships you kind of
learned about men you you learned more
about men to like I I think those chicks
really have to seek out married women to
learn from to counsel women you think
women will teach other women instead of
relationship no I think most women will
lead you to destruction in general I
think women give terrible advice to each
other unfortunately but I do think there
are older women you can talk to that are
married that can give you you good
advice yeah so then then you will be
capable of learning um I don't I
actually have a very pessimistic view um
I got this from my dad I asked my dad
once I said Dad um do people change and
he told me yes yes they do he said they
get worse over time whatever trait you
see now just expect it to be worse in 20
years broke up with my boyfriend that
week I'll tell you
that swear to God anyways anyways um but
but yeah so um I don't think most people
change I think you can but I think a
small percentage of people will
the I am not like that
relationship
um I want to know if the guys can tell
which girls come from like two parent
households and which ones
don't none of you like I
mean wow I don't know I think you um I
mean it's also just like a statistic
fixing like most people AR at this point
um you think them too
um I that's like a crazy one like I'm
not like a complet very good question I
think was that right don't gu don't
don't answer a two parent household like
like initially and then like could have
divorced later on no like like still
together two parent household like well
through the upbringing s until the
person I think you you already mentioned
your family life is a bit skewy so no
I'm say no I'll say yes to you cuz
you're
asking and I'm going to say no and no no
they just recently got a divorce raise
raise your hands if your parents um were
never together raise your hand raise
your par hand if your parents are
divorced okay oh I was right raise your
hand if your parents are still married
married separ my
dad oh you said that I should have known
I didn't say that actually you did say
that young
[Music]
the okay so technically they made it
till you
know [__] I'm not technically [__] it's
um
okay you never had a girlfriend right no
I've never had a like a girlfriend I've
had like serious like like you know
girls I've talked to seriously but not
like hey Mom this is my girlfriend so so
no one that got away then I'm the one
that got away if anything are you
kidding me like let's be realistic here
there's only so many young good-looking
in shaped guys in Miami with money that
have status and a good connection like
I'm not trying to like toot my on horn
but like I'm also realistic like I know
that there's only so many there's frat
guys everywhere there's people working
at McDonald's everywhere there's only
one
sunny but that's why when you said
earlier the wisdom thing that you had
experience I was like but you've never
had a girlfriend so I feel like once you
do get that girlfriend you get that
experience then you'll get a little bit
more insight on being with the women in
me you teach the Matrix no I like I
totally agree with you like my life
point of views are going to change a lot
I just speak from what I've had so far
and I've talked to girls seriously I
mean I've gone on like like a bunch of a
serious talking phase three months of
like talking every day and going on
dates and like okay so three so three
months of talking serious
talking yeah that's mine no no I just I
want to know what's because I'd imagine
I I would think like most talking stages
in general aren't serious unless they
become something right you disagree
agree no I agree because not every
talking stage becomes something I
actually you guys are younger than me so
I don't I'm old all right you're up am I
done I think I think I'm good is it any
of the did the any of the talking phases
are they no I told you I was the one
that got away okay what about what made
you dump them did you dump them um
pretty much every single time there's
like one girl that um it kind of like
fizzled out between us like we literally
just like stopped calling each other but
she was the one that got distant first
but basically every single other girl I
was the one that stopped talking to them
and honestly like I've just been really
focused on business and whatnot like I
know that I'm only 22 years old I'm not
in my Prime as a guy so right now is the
time where I have to focus on myself and
build myself up as much as possible
before I worry about getting like a
long-term serious girlfriend yeah I'm
not in a rush for that [__] like I could
have had a girlfriend it's not like I
couldn't have done it like if you sleep
with a girl you can make them your
girlfriend basically every single time
choose sex and men choose relationship
yeah 100% And um yeah I don't know I've
just been grinding you know like how I'm
on the Pearly things podcast at
22 okay what about you oh yeah I had to
let them all go why well not all of them
but uh virgins yeah that's it's not like
they're like bad girls or anything they
allna my children
no no they were though they were all
teen they were teenagers virgins and uh
yeah that's basically all that really
matters but yeah I was taking the whole
red pill thing too seriously and I was
just dating a bunch of girls like I had
like four girlfriends last summer like I
thought I was uh I don't know I thought
I was like some dating whatever like
like actual series girlfriends like I
was flying to like meet girls parents at
one place and then I was going to meet
the next parents like wow they were like
all really serious they're all really
good girls like one of them came from
royalty and uh then yeah basically yeah
I just was done with all of them except
for my girlfriend now I just why what
happened to the Royal
one uh she does like witchcraft oh okay
or I found out I found out after she
does witchcraft but before she uh I just
I just liked my uh my girlfriend that I
have now too much so I was like ah [__]
these other girl not that my girlfriend
cared I just I was just like annoyed I
was done like I didn't like she from
Miami because surprisingly if you want
to know about I've met more girls
witchcraft in Miami than like well I
think she just liked me a lot and she
saw a Tik Tok video and she tried to
like cast some love
spell how the the Muslim is she gonna
like would she convert to cathol is that
a big oh she's 25% Christian and 75%
Muslim she got baptized oh like three
months ago oh okay cool I let her do her
okay um what about what about you is
there One That Got Away uh yeah so I
used to date a girl who was in opare
which is like a nanny that comes from oh
yeah I had those Germany and whatever um
she German no she was actually Italian
Italian okay yeah but she was from the
UK she moved to Italy when she was like
seven um she was a sweet girl but I felt
like she was trying to marry me for like
a green card for like a Visa no I had
two I swear to God I had two nannies
like one married my uncle yeah off Paris
one married my uncle and one married my
cousin they do that they're trying to
get they're trying to get their papers
yeah
on a one worked out they're still
married one definitely
got to be fair he was kind of crazy too
they kind of deserved yeah she was she
was a she was a really sweet girl like
after I dated other girls after that I
was like damn she was really cool but at
the time I was like 24 25 I was only
making like 60 or 70k a year I just was
like that's the one that got away yeah
like she was a really sweet girl I just
was too young and I you have the
perspective to n good she was compared I
thought she was trying to [__] use me
for a green card and I just couldn't get
that out of my head I was like yo she's
she wants I saw so many girls like you
said they they come over here they date
well my my family with marrying op Paris
was 5050 so you know there are guys that
get hot opars like they they cuz they
get to see the girls on like Zoom calls
sometimes they'll screw the
dads yeah it's not I would hear stories
yeah every every op opir I met like they
were [__] [__] like most most of
them they would go out I'm serious they
would go out nures someone someone get
pregnant they they get sent back home so
we had a lot of actually really great uh
pairs um that actually went on to be
like really good wives good mothers but
we did come with some horror stories and
there is one there was one that we found
out was doing literal like cam work like
she was like she was like yeah she was I
feel like I have such an international
point of VI because I literally had
nannies from Russia South Africa German
like I literally like all over but yeah
this chick was like yeah she was doing
cam work the web cam girl yeah yeah yeah
do you remember where she was from the
that one yeah well uh she was from
Russia I I
Russia yeah well she she I think she
moved I do think like I think she was
culturally Russian but I know she moved
to Germany before like most of my name
that's the first thing that popped in my
head I was like I know she's going to
say R yeah and well and that was the
same Nanny that married my cousin oh D
he does he know does he escalated
quickly well they're divorced now like I
was so young when this happened but yeah
but my cousin was kind of like crazy too
like I think he was addicted to
something like they were both kind of
like like it was a train wreck unstable
but my cousin got clean and remarried
and now he is like a nice congrats to
him now he's got now he's got like
married with kids cousin yeah he turned
his she's a single mother so
[Laughter]
my one that got away is my ex for sure
the only thing that the surfer one no no
the guy one no the the surfer guy was
from Australia the guy I was just broke
up with we were together for nearly four
years we met in Hawaii we moved to Miami
together and the thing that broke us up
is so when we originally got together I
didn't want to have kids and he really
did and we're similar age he's one year
older than me right so he's turning 29
in December
and I think the main thing is that like
he's coming into his prime right now
like he's killing it in his career all
of this so he doesn't want to have kids
and I'm coming to the end of my 20s and
this biological thing has come in all of
a sudden which I could have never
predicted I could have sworn black and
blue I didn't want kids but now I want
kids nearly more than anything and so
that's why we break up we're on
completely different timelines he
decided he didn't want kids when he was
the one who originally did you can get
some crazy genetic right
hereid what I will say is that right now
he we're talking again he's come back
and he's like I don't know if you're can
if you could look at mid-30s then maybe
I could do that but I don't know if I
want to leave that long I'll give you a
couple stats if you guys want a ring I
don't want to wait that long do you want
to know how long it takes you to get a
ring on
average 1.5 years three years two years
maybe years ago no 3 years now so on
average and this is when we started
having these conversations you know
because I was like okay sir this is what
I want and he started going in the
opposite direction that so yeah so if
you meet a guy tomorrow it'll take you
three years to get a ring oh my god wow
yeah on average yeah I thought it was
like six months to a year if what I
thought it was like six months to a year
Well younger younger men aren't really
looking for marriage
how about 30 here's I'll give you guys a
couple depressing stats yeah anyways
that's what I
do but I'll do it with the smile on my
face so yeah if a guy hits 35 and is
unmarried he only has a 15% chance that
he'll ever get married so odds are odds
are yeah you probably will not women
it's a very similar stat um if you are
single by the age of 30 and not in a
relationship you're more likely to never
have children than to have them
no her yeah yeah children on on well if
you're in a relationship at 30 you're
slightly more likely to have children
than not have them but it's still like
pretty high um and I trying to think
about yeah it takes three years on
average and then also the average
engagement is like a year so it takes
like almost half a decade to get a ring
yeah yeah Dam I'm going to be 33 if I
get ring now if I meet but that doesn't
seem that long to me maybe it's cuz I've
been in so many longterm relationship
Rel you're young as well so that doesn't
seem like jarring you're not like oh I'm
not in a rush well the truth of the
matter is I would argue we are in a
postm marriage world and really you're
just kind of going to see marriage
disappear especially from the middle
class I still think you'll see it
amongst like wealthy individuals but I I
see it really disappearing from the
middle class the way that was brought up
marriage is a very big thing in my
culture in my Hispanic culture like you
have to like marriage is very that's
that's the goal in every woman's life
well the the rates of marriage in the
Hispanic Community um are dropping um
and I actually don't even think they're
the most Mar were married for years yeah
no no what I'm saying like over 40 is a
different generation than under 40 true
so so that that generation is different
but I'm saying like the new generation
really getting married half of women
probably won't have kids half will get
married and yeah and then half of the
women that do get yeah because there's
banks that are predicting they're
investing in These Are banks these are
people that have no skin in the game
right zero and they're predicting all of
us are going to be single childless and
so they're investing in things like cat
food um they're investing box wine yeah
yeah because they're literally
predicting that half of women are not
going to have kids out of the half that
do have kids or that do get married
let's say um half divorc and what
percent are single mothers so really I
really only would predict that like 10
to 15% maybe 20% of women will
of our generation at 70 still be married
with
children do you good luck you
know do you recommend like if a
30-year-old to just have a kid oh
no oh no it depends
with I actually I actually I think I
have a little unconservative of a take I
do I actually don't think all women are
meant to have kids especially cut the to
you know some I'm not even like I agree
with that agree that not all women
should be
mothers what well I think like I think
younger women typically can be molded
into mothers but past a certain age if I
was a guy and this would eliminate me
look how nice I am look how honest um I
would only date women under the age of
25 because I've just really I really
what I've seen from thousands and
thousands of show or not thousands
hundreds of shows thousands of people
interviewed is is that women over the
age of 25 typically are too set in their
ways they're not really going to change
you can't really mold them give them a
couple of these so what do you recommend
the woman over 30 what do you recommend
a woman over 30 if we want to talk about
you I I'd say maybe stop with the drug
dealers that was only a few experiences
isn't that and the
thieves yeah um I
mean what okay what outcome do you want
like what do you want no I mean what
else besides having children I mean when
you said no I'm asking like what I think
you're asking for yourself like that's
why okay so so I'm just asking like what
outcome are you looking for do you want
to be
married um my parents are divorced so my
I want to have a kid but I would love to
stay with my partner forever but that's
not like I want to have a kid okay I
can't remember you you are you in a
relationship I'm single okay do you said
my partner forever so I wasn't
okay
um Okay so
well not right now you want you want to
you want to have a child okay how many
dates are you going on a
week zero okay okay okay so zero dates
well all I'm saying like where are you
going to meet men yeah where should I
meet men I don't know
where podcast Home
Depot you go into like Rich Hotel sit in
the lobby looking pasty little Martin
for the doctors and lawyers
okay let's let's talk about this okay
you wanted to go to a a hotel done okay
but but
I'm I'm gonna I'm going to go through
these
scenarios most women do not qualify for
doctors and
lawyers she can date them dating dating
dating is not the same as than getting
married correct so so I think a lot of
times typically as
chicks doctors are like kind of brokies
honestly like they make like 100k a year
and like nowadays that's not even that
much money well if you want okay what
what is the average salary I me average
we're not talking in Our Little World of
internet where everyone thinks they make
200k not even like that but it's like
100k is a lot what percent of men what
percent of men make 100K what is it like
10% 1% okay so it's about 10 so 10% so
would you say that most women at this
table are top 10% no I know but I feel
like we have I don't know I guess maybe
I'm tripping people are average no no
okay today I was just talking about this
with someone actually and they made and
a man and he made it very clear to me
that he does not care what a woman does
at all we were talking about this on the
last show that he felt like a no matter
how smart the woman was no matter what
she brought to the table he did not care
cuz he knows that he's the only one
that's going to have to really bring
anything to the table yeah most men
don't really care what you do exactly so
then how does that factor in with saying
that a woman is not fit to date a a
doctor or a lawyer they care well we're
judged on different things you know one
hotness you feel like
find it well it's rare to get him to
marry and commit to you I'd say your
your odds are slim to none okay I found
my man I'm
attractiv well I would say the odds like
the yeah I would say the odds of you you
I'm just okay I'm just you know I would
say the odds of you really have a happy
ending getting married staying married
to a guy you've known for four days I
would say
slim for four days okay I I know I'm
going this is going to continue I I I
hope I hope I'm just saying a betting
woman if I was like if I was going to
bet I'll call you next year and I'll
show you my rings so what is the
criteria so what is so what is the
criteria that you think a woman has to
fit in order to be the wife or make the
wife of a doctor or a lawyer yeah okay
well number one wait I'm deep in the
[__] you can't wait too long cuz you got
to be
young oh wait oh yeah that's true wait
you like you like fat
chicks cushion for the not not actually
like like obese but like fit
girls cushion yeah yeah I want my girl
be healthy nice so you mean it
proportionally weighted in her bar
basically you don't want an OB check
right now I'm trying to get my
girlfriend as fat as possible to have
beer
always not always just for like health
reasons okay okay okay typically I'm not
talking about this
guy all right so you you wanted to know
I would say men judge you on your body
count now you might not be on your
forehead but usually there are tells and
men can sense that to some
level um I would say you
know you know men judge you on your
class so how you carry
yourself um and your look so don't tell
them about the
scammer I would say I would say dating a
scammer would probably disqualify you
for most high value
men those are the those are the top 10%
of men a lot of women are competing for
them uh so remember they can demand the
best they really can they have choice
and typically they don't choose women
that date drug dealers they wouldn't
know
also
but also but also you ladies wouldn't be
willing to share the man so if you I'll
go picky back off what Pearl's saying if
you're dating a high value man you're
not going to be the main chick like
you'll be the side chick and most of
y'all aren't okay with even being the
side chick to a high value man so you
just got to date regular guys I I'm okay
with that yeah but women say that and
it's not true yeah I haven't dated a lot
of Rich who who at the table's okay with
sharing a guy she said she's okay with
dating a regular man oh but who okay is
at the table well but guys you have to
realize though the men you find
attractive are always top 20% of men
always women find 80% of men to be ugly
not just okay not just eh ugly so even
um like at this table you guys
disqualified all of them should so but
that that's that's of age okay okay but
even I'm older than all of you except
her 35 and I make and I make over 300K a
year so I said you I don't you did say I
was going to say what it no but you
don't know how much I make no no not
about
money and they didn't know his age and
they disqualified him before knew maybe
they they need like a smaller proportion
like well I'm saying if even if you find
a guy that doesn't even if you find a
guy that if you find him attractive he
is likely in the top 20% of guys Oh you
mean in looks and looks and the question
and then the question flips do you offer
more value than the top 20% of girls
most people are average so the odds are
you probably do not you know so I would
ask like then you ask questions and
Kevin Samuels used to do this all the
time he'd say do you have a cookbook
right you know are you are you young are
you under the age of 25 have a Cook's
your weight your dress size right I
think that's a Hispanic thing
though Soul you know do you do you have
a temper how do you handle conflict like
these are I don't have a anymore
progress in that I said that that's
something I can say like the temp that I
had when I was 19 oh yeah us I same I
have a lot more patience you know but I
don't think men are like oh thank God I
have a girl that used to have a temper
no I know they're saying thank God that
I have a girl that has patience now is
what they're worried about they're
worried about who I am now yeah but I I
think like the same way like when a guy
like this is just how I would think when
you hear this it's like they're always
going to think you're going to go back
to that that's true you know yeah and I
think I think most people I mean you
notice on her period like how
I don't get mood on my I get em that's
emotional is you know that's the basics
of time to pick for I defin think you
have to try harder for like High Caliber
you have to like do the most actually in
all in general not just the first three
months you have to wait so what would
you recommend to keep either like a
doctor or a lawyer like high I'd
recommend like for you yeah I just
started I'm here I would I would
recommend uh not you know I would just
recommend taking the L side chick
probably wait why do you want a doctor
or a lawyer a money she's that's not it
I just so happen to meet them where I
work at she she it's not because it's
not because I intended for that it's
because that's what popped up for me
it's not like I was like yo you know how
much money you make it wasn't like that
it was like problem yeah so no there's
nothing I just say like you know you
could win the lottery I hope you do and
I wish you well but I would say like the
odds probably are not in your favor if
you want to be married it's probably
you're going to have better odds with a
regular guy do you think men look at the
amount of money they make
no they do not men do not care they
don't care at all they don't care how
much money you're making honestly
they're young so I think they think
different but they're the first two men
that I've heard say they care a lot
about intelligence usually like I don't
hear men say that that doesn't need to
translate to Inc that doesn't need to
translate to income experience I've been
with like dumb Chi and it gets really
annoying really quicke I just
unfortunately my my brothers um they're
they're like pretty successful guys and
they'll select for for intelligence too
but that's but but that's last yeah
looks like looks come before that you
know so my one brother he he's dating an
engineer that went to culinary or he's
going to get married to an engineer
chick that went to culinary school and
she's hot so he he picked the culinary
so she can cook but she I had this I had
a I had a girl that was extremely dumb
like she thought eggs came from eggplant
like extremely dumb but she was perfect
in every other way she was a great
girlfriend do do whatever I need her to
do but you know my girlfriend now is
very very smart very very intelligent
and when I'm out with her I actually
like spending time with her versus the
girl that's dumb it's like I like
spending time but it's like used for
different things but I want her to just
like you know I want to massage do some
stuff around the house just look pretty
but if I want to actually like I don't
know go do something fun like hike in
the woods and talk it's it's much and
okay so I have a question for you cuz
you said you wanted to have children
right so what's with the why we got the
do you know what those are like like do
you know what they symbolize you know
you what do they symbolize it's the the
the fake lashes like historically
hookers wore those to keep come out of
their eyes say that again hook so when
you wear those that's what you're
signaling to guys when
men that's new information going their
eyeballs this is like our nting call
like
no I I think sometimes they look cute
I'm just saying this is what men
register that I can take them
off don't don't [__] do that that's
weird yeah I mean you guys ask me if I'm
wrong but just when I makeup in general
yeah like heavy makeup they kind of put
you more in the fun category so most the
time I don't wear makeup I wear makeup
when I come podcast and stuff but
throughout my dayto day I don't wear I
think a lot of girls wear eyelashes tto
the to keep up with women fashion the
shirt you're wearing today does that
scream wife and mother like what is that
scream exactly to the and I'm not I'm
not saying I have all the answers but
I'm just you know I could tell you what
what's not the when when you get your
body done like if I see tits I want to
[__] like that's what we think of if we
see a BBL I want to [__] like the first
thing if we see anything over
exaggerated we want to have sex that's
what we think of so every time sex in
general I don't even think it's about
tit if you
have it over exaggerates I honestly
disagree with you on Depot with a big
hoodie and they will still hit on you
well because they can yeah you can smell
yeah you can smell it on you it's
different like I've met like the Virgin
Spain girl and all I could think about I
just want I swear I can I can smell it I
see like
the no but I was saying I've met like
that virgin Spain unvaccinated girl and
like I swear to God this
vated it might sound a little simpy but
like I don't think about just like
having sex with her and like sleeping
with her like I literally think about
like protecting and like I want to just
like hold you I don't know that sounds
like super weird but like they have such
innocence like it's just not the first
thing on my
mind that look like a CH it's not the
it's not the first thing on my mind to
just like rail that girl like she's like
super innocent I don't know know have a
BBL
I there's a difference between
hot exactly hot and beautiful like I
want to date you and you be my
girlfriend versus I just want to like
rail you know pear do you get what I'm
saying or am I know know you're right I
I'll go through just for fun everyone's
got thick skin here I like all of you
but I'm gonna do it yeah so what would
put you in the fun category based on
what you're wearing I would say from my
family this is what my brothers would
say tattoo sorry you would be
gone um Nails you'd be gone hoop
earrings gone eyelash thingies gone uh
you would be all right I
think yeah you'd be all right she'd be
fine yeah she'd be all right yeah for
now for now boobs he would definitely
try to hook up with you but that's
pretty much nose ring gone my brother
won't even dat my brother yeah yeah my
brother won't even date the my brothers
wouldn't my brothers wouldn't even date
the belly piercing yeah wait wait wait
wait so so on top of that the heavy
makeup my the way my brothers my family
would look at that as an expense any any
yeah that's how they yeah they they kind
of my brothers would see the The Fakes
the surgery as an expense I'm have to
spend all this money on this chick no
thank you and they're rich they they do
very well they just don't want to spend
their money nose ring same thing Rich
what yeah um dou doubley baby yeah Nails
gone how are we dressed how are the guys
dressed the guys DN I came dressed
Nic I love this um okay let's see you
know how to play chess I'm not I'm not a
fan of the hat but it wouldn't be like a
I'm trying to be your grandpy but not
yeah I mean fine fine fine yeah I'm
not men's dress doesn't matter to me as
much not are coming in a suit exactly
men and women value different things I
like the suit I think that's nice you
know I like your
jacket but
yeah but yeah did you guys did you what
you actually oh
Jesus kangaroo skin
2021 so did you guys learn something
today oh yeah yeah what a fun panel
[Applause]
[Music]
right um why don't we go around thank
you I've learn I got to go on more dates
with him
before please do don't just move your
kids I'm not going to move over there
without spending time I promise I'm not
that delusional guys yeah yeah always in
the plan if I had all right I'm going to
make some oh I want to make some
predictions who is in a relationship in
here raise your hand who is in your
relationship there was somebody okay
okay I'm
gonna oh you okay okay okay so wait wait
I'm going to predict um you'll date the
doctor for maybe like two three more
months
done um he'll maybe the virtual thing
he'll drag you along for six months
done I every guy made my boyfriend
lasted over seven years with I now
remember I
hope I mean I want nothing more I'm
really to get to that boyfriend level
right so if I said boyfriend it's
because look look it look it she listen
up I and where is that boyfriend friend
now 10 years so that's what I'm saying
but it's always been over it doesn't
it okay it doesn't it doesn't matter
he's gone now it doesn't matter I was 11
okay let's let's go now let's go back to
29 not young old that's why
25 hope this is the last I hope I I hope
I you know I'm going to say a prayer
let's do it because you need
one no no no no I all the I can get I am
not offended by it let's go now okay so
why don't you do final thoughts for all
the men that want to want to court these
women you know they'll give their
Instagrams and whatever so go ahead
final thoughts uh final thoughts I have
realized just how far removed I am from
this generation as far as like my dating
drug dealers for you no I'm good
um yeah no good I'm good um yeah it just
it kind of made me realize that it made
me realize like how far removed I am
from from that idea
of don't change who you are I have a
question do you want to
get
they to her defense please please let
her finish and then we can go around
thank you uh yeah so that that's kind of
like my thing that I've learned um
yeah I've I'm I'm glad I have different
priorities so go ahead final thoughts I
gained more confidence being on the show
definitely top tier I have a cookbook
no um no but really all I kept thinking
about is all men cheat the best way to
avoid that is give your man a threesome
sis that's right damn it you know I I
really did not think that was the
takeaway from today take away I got that
was the takeway I got
take you know I don't know if that's the
key to a long happy marriage but good
luck try it let me know how it goes go
ahead um I did I what I took away from
it was um yeah suggest more modestly I
did listen to you when you said that
will you wear a sweater next time maybe
yeah yeah maybe oh yeah I
forgot that's what
I you learn dress more
okay
amazing the only real
takeway guys guys there's little side
conversations like this but yeah the
only real takeaway I had from this
tonight was like I pray to God that if
any girls are watching this podcast you
wear sundresses drink raw milk don't get
vaccinated and you try to stay pure and
innocent because at the end of the day I
think all of these girls here at this
table know that they messed up and if
they would go back they would stay
virgins until now so really if there's
any girls watching this I Pray
that you stay a virgin until you find a
man that's actually worthy of protecting
and providing for you you hold the power
as the woman of who sleeps with you so
keep that it's not empowering to sleep
with a bunch of people if you have
unlimited access it's the other way
around it's the limiting of it that
gives it the power so stay a virgin at
the end of the day all these problems oh
I'm sorry at the end of the day all
these problems we talked about it boiled
down to body count that's the simple
answer and keeping your legs closed and
I and I agree with you 100% but I'm not
in the business of selling dreams I
predict none of that thank
you sorry I'm kidding no you're good I
are we going around my sh yeah plug your
stuff but yeah Sunny Faz on all socials
I'm the best short form marketer in the
world I do the Consulting in the back
end for a lot of these top influencers
so if you need anything hit me
up I'm just gonna second what Sunny said
Thank you for having me thank you ladies
for sitting down with us it was a good
conversation and uh hey you can find me
on social media at Mayo on Instagram and
yeah I just talk [__] on Twitter ear
Mayo
yeah um I think I lost a few brain cells
but I think I think I think the ladies
were great I think that you ladies need
to lower your standards okay that guy in
your inbox is trying to get through let
him through all right you don't leave
guys on scene go on Dat stop trying to
date doctors and [__] just the guy
that's out there he's he's probably
trying to get to you and you ladies are
playing him so I think you ladies need
to give men uh more chances go out on
more dates for sure um I want to plug uh
the unfiltered podcast um I'm the
producer and co-host so I appreciate
Pearl for having me here um and yeah
that's pretty much all I learned
today highight I I don't know probably
meeting Pearl I've been watching your
content for a while um I very much enjoy
it big advocate for this red pill space
but uh plug you guys can find me on
YouTube YouTube mainly Amy Dangerfield
just hit 16k sub pretty quickly no
that's my real name actually my dad's
name was David Dangerfield that's my
name wow yeah am I wrong it is a little
bit but hey I didn't choose it go ahead
I learn yeah well final thoughts where
people can find you um my Instagram is
Christy allong official and final
thoughts um it was a good conversation
it was fun it was enlightning to say
everybody's different like I said them
two gave me different views that I
usually don't hear from men usually I
hear like opposite like they don't care
about intelligence and things that we
spoke about today so it was refreshing
to see somebody else that actually cares
something more other than just looks but
I still do think that looks are up there
top top priority they don't care they
don't care if you're a fat if you're a
fat like well maybe he does but we send
you like the fatties but but they don't
care if you're a fat smart a chubby
chaser well I don't what you mean by fat
I just can't
imagine the healthier you are it's a
myth that you're healthy when you're
skinny he wants somebody to hold his
baby toxins fat you want to be fat when
you're skinny body is not supposed to be
that I don't I don't want someone to be
like an obese person but there's a lot
of fat people who are really unhealthy
I'm trying to get fat right now sobody
knows I was even skinnier like I've
gained 30 lbs the past like two months
that's crazy be fat it's good for you
don't listen to No it's not good for you
don't get people heart attack if you're
child
die if he heard he's not giving like
context he eats like raw meat raw cheese
raw milk so there's different types of
fat it's not like Denny's fat [__] seed
oil exactly yeah heat very even even bad
fat is healthier than no fat I'll say
that okay so besides that so one another
thing that you had told me cuz you said
it earlier when you're a certain age and
you have kids you do have to keep what
you find and as much as you guys make
fun of 0 four days for this
it's a lot of qualities that I probably
won't find I'm praying you know what I
mean it's a lot of qualities that I
won't find I'm 29 I got kids you know
what I mean so what I'm going to do is
work on spending more time and see if
he's the one and see how it goes yeah
don't mess it up I won't I won't don't
leave him for cheating if he cheats stay
oh no I cheat with him I've been on a
couple of podcasts and honestly I
appreciate the way that you explain
things I think you are more like in that
feminine energy and I appreciate that
because I feel like there's a bunch of
other podcasts that they're way too
aggressive do you get kicked off no I
didn't get kicked off no i y I honestly
gotten lucky so it hasn't been like that
for me but like the way that you move is
perfect I think that's great and I think
people got to see that more because you
you coming with like stats like you're
coming with facts and it's like I don't
got to disrespect you nor do I got to
make you feel little ex get my point
across and I love that so much thank and
you guys were you guys were good fun I
love it when we can go you know go back
and forth no one's mad so so this was
fun um thank you all for coming let's do
a round of applause
for and say my Instagram if any of you
buy their only fans you should be killed
at the steak spicy Vibe XO oh my
Instagram is
4ore yeah spicy Vibe XO all right guys
make sure you like the video on your way
out make sure you subscribe to the
channel bring that notification Bell and
we'll talk to you next
[Music]
time thank
you